good morning everybody I am I'm still waking up oh my gosh I
need 12 30 streams I can't believe I used to stream at 12 p
.m.
like what the fuck was wrong with me I could barely be awake
at 12 30 I remember when I used to stream at 12 p.m.
and then I was like I can't guys my body is not
and that's like 12 30 I was like why oh my god who I thought
30 minutes does no difference at all my body is still so
weak good morning everybody I'm so excited to play part two
of settling I want to do like before we start i want to do a
huge shout out to uh bandai for um also giving us i believe
six codes for sandland two for pc two for playstation and
two for xbox so um if you somehow got the playstation code
and you don't have a playstation well uh that well Actually,
you couldn't because you have to activate that code on your
PlayStation.
So at the end of the stream, I would highly, I would be
giving out these codes at the end of the stream.
So what I'll be doing is that I'll just be pasting the
codes.
I'll just give a countdown for all you guys.
And I'd be like pasting the codes in chat at the end of the
stream.
codes and Xbox codes so I assume that like it works on
either I assume okay so like all you have to do because like
PlayStation 5 has like uh what's the word called it has like
uh backwards compatibility for PlayStation 4 so like all you
have to do is just um at the end of the stream just have
your PlayStation PlayStation or Xbox out in advance so like
you can like fight for the code it's basically whoever puts
the code down the fastest would basically activate it.
So all you have to do is just have your fucking PlayStation
Xbox ready to activate the code on your console.
So, and it's just whoever activates it first gets the game.
Miracle, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
But yes, so it'll be two PC codes, two PlayStation codes,
and two Xbox.
goods again like a huge shout out for bandai for uh giving
us these codes as well as the collectors sending me a
collector's edition of the game i really honestly did not
expect it i don't know if you guys know this but like bandai
was like one one of the games i couldn't really play back
then uh because you know perms so i was like super surprised
not gonna lie i was so surprise with how supportive they've
been uh with sandland and how supportive they've been of me
like playing like a lot of their other games because i've
always wanted to play like digimon games um before then but
i couldn't so like it's really really i'm really thankful
for bandai uh to like you know supporting me be like
encouraging me to play more bandai games as well so yeah
thank you again i really appreciate it because like that
means i can finally play like digimon world like i i've
always wanted to play i've always wanted to play digimon
world and i'm so happy i'll actually be able to like try it
out in the future uh who's jerky's digimon favorite my
favorite has to be either uh terrier mon uh terrier mon
gabumon and also uh renamon uh honestly like gen 3 of
digimon what is it called gen i don't remember if it's
series 3 series 3 of digimon is like the most optimal
digimon designs in my opinion um the only like digimon
designs i oh gotomon too i really love gotomon as well
gotomon uh terrier
and I think that's really it but like I'm gonna say Gabumon
fell down in my love for his design because I talked about
this before but I realized he's wearing a skinned animal I
just I realized like if you guys didn't notice he's not
actually like the fucking thing he has on top of him is like
his fur it's not even his fur and then you take it off it
looks so ugly like people were like what does it look like
underneath and then i like looked up like like they're like
fan designs of what's underneath gabumon and um and every
time i look at it i it just ruined gabumon for me i just i
just can't i can't take like gabumon seriously knowing like
what it could look like underneath and it's just i'm sorry
he's so ugly
He's just, I'm sorry.
Like, the, the, the, without the pelt, he's so ugly.
And I can't, like, change my love for Gabumon.
Because all I can think about is what's underneath the pelt.
Well, okay, do you guys not know?
Okay, here.
This is, like, what people think Gabumon looks.
Because he's has a double chin.
I don't know if you guys notice.
But, like, the pelt hides the fact that he has, like, double
chin so it looks so weird it looks so weird without the pe
because then it's like it's like accentuates the double chin
and i'm like oh poor kabuman
like look at this like what the fuck is this like look
there's a double chin what do you mean Look, it's right
here.
Do you not see it?
It's right here.
I'm not crazy It's literally right here That's why he's so
cute All right, yeah, it's like a guy that shaves off his
beard So that's just a lie
That's a fan design.
It doesn't count.
It won't hide the fact.
It won't hide his chin.
Like his chin was the only thing that's exposed.
Anyway.
Um.
No matter what.
We all know what's underneath.
It's not as cute as what's like what he has.
Like.
Um.
But yeah.
Anyway.
I used to really like Gobble.
man and uh joki is a ditchy chamber anyway as i was saying i
used to really like gabo man but then like my whole love for
gabo man basically like um died i still he's still in my top
five designs it's just that you know i realized he wasn't as
cute as i thought he was because the all the the cute factor
comes from the the thing he's wearing so so I was just like
oh yeah I was just in love with the fur design I was in love
with him and he died it's not even his fur that's the thing
it's not even his fur so like I'm not even in love with like
him it's like I was in love with what he was wearing so it's
not really him he basically like skinned at somebody else's
fur and put it on top of him so whichever fur that came from
that's the design i'm in love with you only liked him for
his fur damn right i'm not fucking ashamed of that i read it
um jl thank you for the super chat my kamioshi exposing
gabumon like thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you um uh but yeah uh i'm really thankful for bandai for
reaching out and uh like and um uh and supporting this
playthrough i don't know if you guys saw but like uh you
guys all know like this is actually like the very last name
that toriama was involved in um so like as i say this trip
team playing this game sort of like a uh like uh loki like
tribute to him and everything but this was like the last
game he was actually like publicly involved in and they even
like put up he even had like a statement written for this
game um before he passed away um i was like reading the
statement and he was like really proud of this game and like
really proud of like the world that was developed for this
game because there's like stuff that's not in the manga that
like they added in and things that he wanted to be added to
the manga that um that like they ended up adding in the game
for um so i'm really looking forward to playing more of uh
sandland i'm really looking forward um anyway guys let us
start the game i played around the volume a little bit more
uh last not last night last playthrough before we ended the
playthrough so i don't know if sound guy is here at the
moment uh yes you must return do you wish to yes okay it's
gonna be in japanese now i hope hope you guys are happy you
guys know the reason why i play in english is so that i
don't have to read like i won't be reading it out loud to
you guys okay all i'm saying is that you voted for japanese
so i will not be reading out the english dialogue like you
It's like subs versus dubs now.
All right.
Why?
Because you guys voted for the Japanese dub.
What do you mean?
Why not?
You guys had a choice.
All right.
Let us go.
I never fucking remember how to play this game.
All right.
How does she sound like?
Oh, Luca was in.
garage.
Oh, this is like the stuff.
Wait, do I have to upgrade my stuff again?
Did I upgrade anything?
I don't remember.
No!
Okay, give me a sec.
I'm gonna load game.
Give me a sec.
I'm pretty sure I saved it, right?
Load game.
A jump bot?
Wait, did I not?
Oh, fuck.
I forgot to save it.
Okay.
Guys, I've I forgot to save after upgrading my fucking tank.
We got to...
Alright.
Did I upgrade my parts at least?
No, I didn't!
Oh my god.
Okay, here we go.
Here we go again.
Alright.
I know we upgraded this.
Like, I remember that.
Okay.
Alright.
Customized vehicle.
Uh, how do I...
Okay.
Oh, I can rename.
it all right we're gonna rename our vehicle uh how do i go
what the fuck how do i have to rename it on my oh i have to
rename it here dragoons one that means there's might there
might be a dragoons too the possibility that there's a
dragoon too
All right, let's see.
Can I upgrade vehicle?
Upgrade vehicle.
All right, let's see.
I'm going to upgrade the vehicle.
Try this to see soon.
All right, vehicle level.
I can go all the way.
Let's go.
Whoa!
I'm so...
Okay, I don't have any more.
I'm going to say, whoa!
I have so much stuff.
Oh my gosh.
I can't believe I didn't realize that I have to upgrade
these parts.
as well.
All right, let's see.
Oh, wait.
Customized vehicle.
Chip slot.
What did I want?
Power?
It was power, right?
Yeah, power chip.
Okay.
Here we go.
Uh.
Upgrade.
Okay.
All right.
Upgraded all of these.
Upgrade part.
Upgrade vehicle.
Uh.
Can these be upgraded?
Choose a part.
Okay.
Wait, what?
The upgrade is the wrong thing?
No, I didn't.
Okay, I did not.
Okay, I just...
Oh, shit.
Okay, give me a sec.
Okay, no, I didn't.
Oh, thank God.
Okay, I did not upgrade the wrong part.
I just have to be sure.
Reload time.
Attack interval.
I feel like it doesn't.
They both are very similar.
uh upgrade there you go okay i've already upgraded that all
right nice all right we're good select vehicle oh yeah i
should have a jumper right now right where's my jumper no i
don't dragoon 2 would be the jump the jump one the jump tank
all right all right here we go let's see gotta talk to this
guy now all right and then can I save here save data okay
there you go oh my god I never saved I just I just relied on
auto save all right uh Phelan think about 10 give the ships
they can thank you a request wants me to do shit again
Machine gun scrapped is what I need.
How can you do it?
Oh, but housing me, like, a...
I thought I had a huge bounty on me at the moment, but it's
okay if they housed me, I guess.
They're like, we don't want to bring ourselves attention to
the army.
But anyway, feel free to live in this place.
Oh my god, money!
I love doing things for money.
that's my job all right let's see we wanna oh hey they fixed
it i just realized okay max the master volume okay got you i
like how they fixed the uh i don't know if you guys
remembered but we had an issue on launch where everything
was just flickering so you know it's good that they fixed
that they actually fixed it give the machine oh i already
did it oh did i do it already obtain some machine gun mayor
i did it i was fixing my settings but i did your job mayor
it was so easy
yay ray hammer welcome to tomato farm welcome welcome
Okay, he has everything he needs.
Oh, I get to keep it?
Nice.
I got to keep the rest.
Isn't that great?
I did it, guys!
All I did was look at my menu and I completed my job.
I wish things were that easy.
What?
It's a singing ship?
What do you mean by that?
I thought this was like a utopia.
What's going on?
No!
How can it fail?
It has a population of like five people.
I don't understand.
No!
We'll just, we'll just deconstruct a garage and reconstruct
it later.
There's only like two kids in this town.
All right, for an old friend's son and wife to look after
them.
Who's Hugh and Plika?
Is that the kids?
I'm sorry, I forgot the names.
Oh So it's like so see just tell them tell them like his
grandpa hates him then they'll understand it's a lot But it
will be a good lie
Yeah, you want the kids to die in this town?
That's so fucked up lady Oh shit I like how these guys are
just listening into this very private conversation i i i
like uh they're just listening it is standing there and
being listening to this family drama like some fucking
television show
oh so they don't have food or water that's why this town is
dying to be fair there's like no young people in this town
it's Except for that one lady.
Good listeners.
Does it help?
It doesn't even help.
Nobody moves in.
But they're like, like oh we want to attract more people to
spin you but it doesn't help there's no new people coming in
that's the whole problem they're not doing anything there's
no new people even if they're like oh this town is amazing
we don't have food or water like no matter how you gas up
this town work because there's no food or water let's tough
it out just a little longer mayor
this is up logic that doesn't solve the food problem
Oh my god, we're gonna do our job.
All right, nice.
We're gonna...
The Demon King shall help.
Because that's what we know about the demons.
They love helping people.
Oh, the jump butt!
So how's the sound sound guys?
They don't know who we really are.
I don't know man.
A pink boy is a very like...
very like specific description sir we're looking for a boy
that's fucking pink
all right
Don't be like you fucking failed old man I hope you guys are
like reading in time with this exact same time as me And I'm
not going too fast
I don't know how I'm reading as fast It's like too fast or
not
I'm not reading.
Let's see what.
Oh, we're back here.
All right.
She's working on the jump battle on her own.
yeah yeah he used to he fucking used to be in the army so he
should know where the main base is
Wait, we've fucking saw all of this before.
Wait, did that mean I was like a fucking eavesdrop before?
Wait, this is the same.
I didn't even realize we've seen this cutscene.
Did we not?
Do we?
Okay, I saw this.
Sorry, we're skipping.
I know we saw this.
Wait a minute.
Alright, we're going to skip.
We don't need a recap, guys.
It's going to be like the Netflix.
Like, skip the intro.
yeah I was like wait a minute I remember this it was him
I mean we see how it's different from like the original
voice from the not the English voice acting previously on
Sandland skip skip skip skip skip skip skip skip guys if you
want oh my god there it is i was like where's the actual
skip button uh here we go we can re-watch the scene all
right bet son If I'll crash or not
Guys, if you were like Don't get why to watch this scene
Literally just play the last Like five minutes of my vibe
From the first playthrough
But we only know how it sounds In English The real fiend
here
The real fiend here.
It's actually me!
That's right, you're a fucking war criminal.
Live and die with your guilt.
Absorb.
Welcome to the Toriyama Cinematic Universe.
I'm going to turn into a giant monkey now.
Alright, here we go.
This is where I crashed.
Maybe they patched it.
Maybe they patched it?
Oh, thank God.
I was like, oh, please don't be the Doki jinx.
And it actually crashes.
I have expected it to crash.
Not gonna lie.
I was like, oh, no.
I might have jinxed it.
All right.
Sound guy, I up the volume again.
Let me know if it's better.
Then go to the suspense.
I know.
I was like, uh-huh.
Uh-huh.
Oh!
Okay, sorry.
Now I remember why we never saved.
It didn't crash, but at what cost?
What's the car?
That's not the jump bot.
Yeah, let's say.
Oh,
here's the badness we beat up.
Because they're dying in the sad land.
People would fucking kill at that point.
It's literally anime maniacs.
Of course.
Yay!
I got my car back.
Oh shit, I get the car.
at my own car say no more say less yeah they stole my
dinosaur too i can't believe i got gtd
oh you're right where's my jump bot jump maker
I really love the 3D models on these.
They look so...
They look like...
They really look 2D and 3D at the same time.
Wait, were you going to, like, invade their base again?
you know what i'm just happy about i'm just really happy
that like for an anime adaptation of a like for like a game
adapted from a anime slash manga that's not a fucking
fighting game
tired of game adaptation that's just a fighting game I don't
care what anybody says I'm so fucking tired of it there's
the whole world we need more anime fighting games you can
have bro that's basically like 90% of Dragon Ball Z games
but at least it makes sense because it's Dragon Ball Z
there's some fucking anime fighting games that don't fucking
make sense at all all right let's see let me push push the
volume overall volume a little bit more guys uh sound guy
requested all right I pushed it up Let me know if that's
better.
Guys, I'm like this close to having like putting it back in
English.
Because I'm tired of reading already.
Okay, all right, well, we've had, we've had, we got her, we
got her Japanese at Toba.
I'm sorry, guys.
I'm just not as strong.
Okay, reading is so hard.
I'm like reading and also trying to think at the same time.
And that's like, I haven't done that since university.
And I'm too tired too right now.
Finally, I don't have to read.
Gladstone, don't.
Oh, a little bit too late there.
Gladstone, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Reading the game and reading.
the chat there's just too much reading going on my brain
just cat i lasted 36 minutes i did i don't think it was even
36 because there was like a time where we had to do other
stuff all right here we go back uh we have to assemble the
we have to go back and forth all right and we brought the
bloop
this should do the trick yay we did it right away help i
have enough parts now we have the jump bot To create a
vehicle frame, money, and other necessary parts.
I have money!
How do I do this?
Make a part.
You need money materials to make parts.
Select the vehicle type with LB and select part to make.
Choose and build.
Okay.
Oh, there it is.
Uh, we need this.
Okay, we got that.
And then we need to make this.
Nice.
I knew being a Luke Goblin, what's the way to go?
No, I need a fucking scorpion oil and raptor seal?
Oh, I'm too lazy.
I'll fucking, I'll go with default.
I don't want to farm.
I'm too fucking lazy for that.
I think that's it, right?
I made it.
Did I make everything?
You should be made.
Did I not make you?
Did I...
Oh, go to make vehicle.
Okay, vehicle.
Make vehicle.
Alright.
Nice.
Okay.
Once you have what parts are required, go to make parts.
Okay, I did it.
Alright, nice.
So let's start to create part...
Okay, I'm going to create part four once I set up slots.
Okay.
Nice.
I made you.
You can never leave When you live under this house Alright
Assemble
Alright Dragoon Better Dragoon
Two There we go Why couldn't you be just like my Better
Dragoon Dragoons Why could you be just like him Damn.
See you later.
I make it.
Cool.
Drag hoot.
I can't believe you really made it.
I did.
What you're talking about?
You didn't think she could?
I'll be honest.
I had my doubts.
You must have had a fine mentor.
I said, yeah, how's the voices now?
No.
mentor for me i'm completely self-taught she watched those
youtube videos there's just always been a lot for me to
tinker around with incredible in any case this should allow
us to slip past the army and continue on our journey south
yeah we can jump now i don't know this does not look like
sneaky when can i upgrade my X base Almost like it's fate
Alright then Let's get a move on already What happened to
the Japanese dub I got tired of reading
It's too early in the morning for me Prince Before we head
to the East Valley Let's scout the southern road What for?
Why the scout?
I want to see what the army might be able to throw at us.
Oh, we're going to test it out.
Okay.
Wait, is there more talking?
And we talk like every day.
What else do you want?
When can I customize my fucking...
Uh...
When can I customize my like fucking...
Like...
Wait, what did I want to customize?
Oh, my town!
Sorry, I lost my chin.
This is exactly why we have to put it back on English.
I actually lost my train of thought in the middle of
thinking about it.
So that girl, Anne.
Uh, you mean me?
Yeah, her.
What about her?
Yeah.
Been thinking.
She's a good girl.
Oh.
Oh my god, that's creepy.
That smile.
I'm afraid I don't follow either.
She's a good girl.
oh hey oh that's smile bro she was enjoying herself so much
it was positively infectious just watching her work put this
car lover in a good mood oh car lover next time come over to
say hello
You need a supervisor there if he's there alone with you
too.
You cannot be alone with this man.
Do you not see how he fucking smiled at you?
Cars are awesome.
I sure wish I had my own.
Oh, so you're a stranger danger.
Oh my god, it the fuck is wrong.
Then you should really head to the junk pit.
He needs a chaperone.
a bodyguard junk pit turn right at the fork leading to the
lease of junkers market there's a pit where junkers toss all
the stuff he just really really loves cars you don't
understand I'll get a car maybe not a whole car but you
Might find a friend.
Do not go to that mad junk space.
Okay, car park.
Oh, these are all like side quests.
I can't wait to not...
Oh!
Najinbu!
Hey, nice to see you again.
Is it just my imagination?
Or has the town gotten more lively?
Oh, yeah.
I found something Oh my god, thank you for the free stuff,
Miaojinbo.
Okay, uh, do I have anything?
I need, like, two ancient coins?
Bring me any rare items you find.
I'll make it worth your while.
What are you gonna do with the ancient coin?
You want me to fucking...
You want me to fucking, like, ruin more ancient ruins?
That's why it's called ruin.
Sorry, I'm gonna discover...
i'm here to discover more national treasures i uh i'd heard
demons were attacking passers-by stealing water and such
water but there's so much water behind you wait i thought
you guys were attacked like no food and water what is that
behind you i i i just got scared well there's some truth to
that but it sounds like back to the museum you're right
attacking passers-by we only take what we need from the
royal army exactly from the army you go up against yeah
because apparently the army is more evil than fucking satan
himself you must be really strong then sure am and i'm only
nine no wonder you can travel the dangerous sandland
unscathed that's bleach what the fuck i guess you're too
strong to find it dangerous but to us humans stepping
outside town isn't something you do lightly just traveling
those weak flesh bodies but with the risk of bandit and
raptor attacks as well we're risking our lives every time we
go to another town that bad it is I can't travel alone
either yeah I can tell why Even seasoned peddlers have to be
careful You basically let a little boy do all the fighting
for you I can see why you can't travel alone You're a goner
So you need luck just to reach your destination Wait is this
an escort mission I guess that means I was lucky to meet you
guys Talking about all this has got me feeling a bit uneasy
She looks like chichi But with brown hair Well wears from a
merchant oh my god have you guys seen like pakora has been
like doing like the dragon ball z streams and stuff and like
i she's never fucking watched or played any dragon ball z
like dragon ball games and it's actually or read any dragon
ball before so she like basically went in with zero
knowledge of dragon ball and i was like how like i can see
if you're like
That's just insane That is just I was like that's actually
crazy like growing up in Japan and never reading watching or
playing any dragon ball game.
That's I just like That blew my fucking mind when I when I
heard He's always had incredible luck so I didn't think much
of it but what if he's in trouble so it's actually like she
actually goes in with zero knowledge and like like reacting
to it live for like first time seeing all these things so
like a lot of drag obviously like you know dragon ball is
like a huge like cultural phenomenon like overseas and also
domestically and the so like people like are watching it
because it's like you get to see an actual first time live
reaction of somebody like never who's never had any
background information about dragon ball like experiencing
it for the first time so they're basically like reliving
their life like they're watching it so they could like um
what's their word called it's like outer wilds like
basically reliving the experience through her type deal um
beelzebub if you ever see that merchant in trouble during
your travels could you please help him out maybe if i'm in
the mood thank you i'm counting on you and they're living
vicariously through her to re-experience dragon ball z for
like as if it's like the first time again which is very rare
it's actually i like i actually blew my fucking mind that
she never had any like dragon ball knowledge before playing
the game because she doesn't know anything that's going on
and she's like what like what the fuck
all right it's time to go
how far did i know the dragon ball arc pretty far i've
actually like i watched i watched dragon ball from like like
the when he was a little kid to uh to like i was a gt i
watched i didn't i didn't watch all the gt because it's gt
not okay i don't know much about i don't know much about
like the the world saga like the world tournament not is it
the world tournament who the fuck is this guy oh is do i
save him oh i guess i'll save him no my fucking taxi
Okay, hello.
Hello.
Intimidate.
No!
Don't run away!
I can't believe it.
My dad, oh, he ran away!
My car ran away!
Give me the fucking money.
Why do you have your eyes closed?
well well well well what was it the universe tournament well
the one where like like the like the universe tournament not
the world tournament the i stopped i i haven't watched
dragon ball super is it is it super the one with like that
was like the sequel to dragon ball z because like we don't
we don't talk about tt uh shark that's like living in
america can a year i'm never playing halo oh wait that's me
i never played halo the multiverse tournament yeah yeah like
the only thing I know about super is the the cat guy the cat
guy and then like the the tournament of power and I know
about the tournament power arc because I I watched a little
bit of it because I thought it was super interesting and uh
and I watched like a little bit of the tournament power arc
and like read the Wikipedia of like everything about the
tournament of power because I thought it was like a super
interesting And then that's the only thing I know about
Dragon Ball Super.
If it's not one thing, it's another for this guy.
And here I thought that with the Raptors gone, I'd finally
get to make my deliveries to Spino.
Oh, you're a delivery man?
Spino?
Wait, are you a peddler?
Yeah, what are you?
Indeed, I am.
Then hurry before you get attacked again.
80s is waiting Oh You know 80s Yeah, I know 80s.
Are you the one who drove that raptor away?
Yeah, that's me They were snapping at my heels.
So I sent them flying that's all Even so it doesn't change
the fact that you saved me Here take this as thanks I don't
want it.
No, what I do Don't say that.
If I don't thank you properly, my wife is somewhere.
What the fuck do you mean?
I want it.
Instead of don't want your thanks.
Don't force it on me.
Well, then I'll follow your advice and hurry on to Spino.
Bye.
Give me a break.
What's wrong with that guy?
What the fuck he gave you something?
And you're like, what the fuck is wrong with him?
He gave me free shit.
Like, what's wrong with you?
Like, Painter, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
the dokey supremacy continues think about the super chat
thank you thank you i can't god damn it be so buff we love
free stuff i got like one experience for that that's
actually crazy guys i have to go back for my car actually no
i don't need it let's try the jumper bot let's see how
that's like where would the others get on okay autopilot
move leave vehicle boost Shoot.
Hold to aim.
Reload.
Okay, I'm going to forget, like, majority of this.
So yell at me if I don't remember.
Wait, where are the others?
Do they just not exist?
Oh, my God.
Look at me go.
I wish I had my raptor.
Okay, we got to go East Valley water supply point.
Gifted flowers.
Do I care enough about the people?
Okay, wait.
There's just a junk pit, the diamonds boss.
All right, we gotta run.
All right.
You're just gonna run.
Oh my god, we're going 49 kilometers per hour.
Make sure to check your gear every now and then.
What's that supposed to mean?
Never know when something you've picked up might come in
handy.
What the fuck does that mean?
I'll give him a look.
Okay, I'm gonna...
What does this look like?
Broom.
Okay, that's what that does.
And then...
mid-air okay and then the stop move and all right reload all
right we got this oh my god look at all these oh my god
there's so many babies oh my god it's so easy to kill them
look at all these children wait they have to run behind me
okay that's pretty funny
There's only one left.
I like how the NPCs are just following behind me.
All right, nice.
It's okay.
There's still one more left.
It's not...
What the fuck?
The Teredactals hate me as well?
But why?
I'm a good person.
What did I do?
I basically...
Oh, I...
killed like i must have like killed because they need it
they need the the babies to eat all right let's make sure we
kill these people sorry not kill um just like injured them a
little bit you know because we don't kill guys remember guys
i don't know you guys remember this but we don't kill in
this universe because killing it is a lie we will never
cross see we can we gotta get rid of him and him.
Alright, we did it.
Oh my god!
Assimulate time.
This is mine now.
Oh shit.
We gotta shoot some birds down.
There can only be one bird in the sky.
Don't get a child.
We're here.
Back at...
Wait, he gets his own car.
Okay, I like how he like follows me with his car.
Okay, that's nice.
That's it.
That's pretty good.
I like that, actually.
He just follows me in his own car.
No one's safe from me.
The baby is easier to kill.
It's just stomping on some bugs, guys.
No big deal.
Did I kill him?
Wait, no, I didn't.
Alright, don't worry.
Don't worry.
You're gonna be a widow now.
Actually, no.
Let's just kids have the orphans.
Alright.
Nice.
The kids have more loot.
No, the moms have more loot, so it makes more sense to just
kill the mom.
The kids don't give as much.
See?
Look, the mom gave me, like, venom and the exoskeleton.
Alright, we're gonna loot this.
Loot.
The desert gets off.
i'm just doing my part exactly i'm doing my part we're
playing hell anime hell divers too jacob welcome to the
tomato farm welcome welcome we seem to be more vulnerable to
pretty much every this game has everything anime mad max
anime hell divers anime wow their defenses are much stronger
than i expected guma welcome to tomato farm welcome welcome
i like that you guys join the tomato farm the moment i
started killing kids like i don't know what that says about
you as well it's practically a fortress there's no breaking
through that as expected we'll have to take a detour via
east valley
what's this whoa teriyashiva wowza that's my lucky charm
whoa yeah how lucky wait a minute wait a second wait a
minute what do you do in this tank what did you do in this
tank used to be a famous movie star sexy terrier you might
act like a stick in the mud but it looks like you're a dirty
old man shut up and sit down we're moving out yeah he's a
dirty old I can't say it I can't say it planning to face the
army old man is that what the lucky charms for what but you
said we weren't going to fight the royal army but the old
man's obviously got to pay the royals back for what they
pulled on him hold on please tell me you're joking that was
30 years ago it's your fault thief wait why was it his fault
what did you do.
Wait, what?
How did you shift the blame to him?
He's literally just like the fucking third wheel.
But if the royal army gets in my way, I'll gladly take them
on.
I'd give my left arm for a chance at Supreme Commander Zayu.
Poor man.
He gets like fucking...
What?
Who the fuck is this guy?
Look, he's just catching some strays
Who's this game?
Oh my god, Papa!
That's your...
Bro, okay, if he has a bod like that, yeah, I'm not
surprised he's fucking not wearing anything.
Bro, he's got a flexit man.
If he hasn't, he's got to show it.
How the fuck do I get there?
It's like here.
There's no fall damage anyway.
Oh my god!
Guys, it'll be okay.
It's just a flesh wound.
See?
Nothing bad happened.
Guys, nothing bad happened.
god you mean i wasn't supposed to fall down no i fell down
for no reason
oh that seems like something i do there's supposed to be a
price on our head there's that's that's something i do we'll
have to be on the lookout for not just the army but bounty
hunters okay wait maybe i can i can salvage this guys guys i
can salvage this guys it's parkour time you're worried about
her no it's okay big time if our bots broke down and we
didn't have her around to fix them it's okay guys there has
to be a way to cheese this girl safe in spino oh my god i
knew it i knew it if there's a way i will skyroam this shit
if I have to.
I knew they would build a Skyrim for me.
I knew it.
It's like I didn't fuck up.
We actually did it.
Woo!
I am determined.
Where's a horse what you need?
If only you had a jump, bot that could jump.
No!
Okay, let's get the jump pot out.
All right, now we need the jump pot.
There is a jump that I cannot make.
No!
Okay, okay.
Guys, guys, there's a delay when it comes to jumping.
Did you guys know that?
What the fuck am I?
Okay.
There's like a delay you don't understand!
Like, what is this bullshit?
Are you fucking- I- Bro!
It's gonna break!
No!
Game over!
Okay, okay, guys, there's a delay!
Like, what the fuck?
Okay, all right, okay, we're gonna track it.
There's a delay in jumping.
I swear to God.
Okay.
Like, I can't stop the delay.
The go!
What?
This is bullshit.
This is actually bullshit.
Okay, here we go.
Oh my god.
I did it.
I fucking did it.
Guys, I beat.
hard mode guys this is the hardest part of the game this is
this is the hardest part of the video game chat you don't
understand you don't understand how difficult that was for
me we could reach it okay oh loot nice oh thank god i have a
robot that can jump oh now it fucking responds this is
bullshit this is actually bullshit this is this is a
cover-up from the government the government doesn't want
people to know how good I am at video games so they
purposely add a nurse for me like it's not a conspiracy if
it's true the government purposely added lag so I wouldn't
so I wouldn't hit those jumps.
They added latency on my jumps.
They didn't want my true power to show up.
They're pretty much everything.
She's catching on.
Quick, somebody.
How's the volume so far?
Is it like, oh, loud enough or too loud?
Just want to be sure.
Bro, I'm so mad I'm gonna start killing the wildlife
It's the leader of the raptors the leader this guy Bro, I
can just shoot the raptors But I have to be careful of like
look I could just do this You oh shit like see look at that.
I could just do this wait Wait, he can't fucking leave Wait,
he's stuck.
Oh, he's not stuck guys stuck oh what the fuck okay okay
it's okay there's no way he's gonna kill me wait he has fire
I could jump I could jump from that okay one more hit one
more hit nice we did it see oh it just gives me like five
raptor skills the air shot they It won the true power of the
silver unleashed upon them.
Breeze, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
They're hiding my true power in my power level chat.
It's the government.
That is a conspiracy I'm willing to get behind in.
Wait.
Okay, there you go.
Alright, now I don't have any repair kits.
This is gonna be a little bad.
Am I going the right way?
It's like here, right?
The East Valley?
Yeah, alright.
It's here.
we're gonna get rid of the scorpions all right we're gonna
make more orphans eventually those orphans are gonna find
the the moms that i spared and then i'm gonna and then
they're gonna thank me all right and then i'm gonna kill the
kids here so then the the mom can adopt the orphans that i
made behind me and then there i saw the orphan problem and
then they're gonna like love each from the trauma they built
together.
What's this?
They're gonna thank me for thank me for saving them.
Their family bond is gonna be stronger than blood.
Because I basically...
Oh, the sand fall.
I did a risky mission.
Give me the money.
Thank you.
I only do this for the money.
Wait, is that bad guy?
Oh, that's so pretty.
That's fucked.
It's not fucked up!
Because if you don't have more...
It's only fucked up because you still have empathy.
Okay, wait.
Can I have him, like, shoot things for me?
It's called practicality.
Nice, let me...
So it's extra fucked up.
Okay, let's grab this.
I want the gems.
I like how I can farm these things without having to get off
the...
Get off the jumper bot.
Is there anything above me?
I feel like there's something above me.
That's even more fucked up.
God, you sound like somebody that has moros.
Who still has that?
What's over here?
Is this, like, a secret area?
No, I don't know if I should go this way.
I'm not going this way.
They're children?
I thought Morales got patched.
Oh my god.
Morales in 2024.
Morality.
This is why we got rid of the morality system.
It's actually true.
I don't know if you guys noticed this.
But like, I feel like more and more recent games.
Like games that used to have a morality system.
They got rid of the morality system.
Because they realized gamers don't care about.
Have you guys noticed that?
Like, some games that used to have, like, morality system,
they, like, patched it.
They got rid of it.
We go to any things.
We definitely need, like, repair kit, guys.
Okay, repair kit.
Oh, wait, no, I shouldn't sell it.
I want to buy a repair kit.
Okay, I'm going to buy two.
We might as well.
We don't...
We have a lot of money, right?
Yeah, we have a lot.
Thank you.
yeah undertale yeah but do you remember do you know how old
undertale is a lot of like more recent triple a well i would
say triple a games but a lot of like more recent video games
have gotten rid of it
gta would need more of a cascade lies not far to the west of
here it's a sight to behold definitely worth a look while
we're in might as well while we're here guys i'm still okay
okay
we how do i how do i miss that jump oh my god did my mpc die
with me i hate this i actually hate this i
no no no no no no no no no no This fucking sucks!
Okay.
I blame the government.
The government is adding latency to my game.
I swear to God.
It's not me.
This must be the East Valley by all appearances.
There's a lag.
I swear.
There's like lag.
Oh, it's so tall.
No way we could have climbed up there without the jump bot.
and the legendary spring awaits on the other side right i
doubt it'll be quite that simple even so it's a big step
forward well what are we waiting for let's get up there
okay we gotta jump okay we also gotta heal uh we did it we
healed all right here we go how do we get up there do we
jump from here would barely even tickle.
Okay, we got this.
Look at that.
I'm figuring it out.
See, look at, this is what my true power is like without the
government trying to nerf me.
Look.
Oh, and then suddenly there's no latency between my jumps.
Like, what?
Coincidence?
I think that.
Don't fall out.
Defeat Toki platforms.
Come on.
Come on, thief.
Tired already?
You need to get off your butt more than once every hundred
years.
Easy for you to say from a jump, but...
Huh?
What?
Whoa!
Shoot the rock!
Oh, jump?
Close!
Okay, just shot the rock.
It's a rock.
Papa!
oh
Don't worry just keep going I'm sorry like I like how the
the guy in the far left just doesn't have a fucking nose He
just has two holes like what?
Pike sketch all their faces for me, would you?
Coming right up
The fuck is he what what is?
What is he doing?
They have good team chemistry.
What a team.
Wait,
they know who I am?
That's me.
How does he know who I am?
Everyone just...
Oh, I've beaten him up before.
You know, this guy waxes, too, because, like, there's
literally no hair on any of them.
My God.
That's swimmers.
He waxes all the hair off except for the mustache.
And be ready to run if it doesn't work.
Okie dokie.
Dokie, please.
Look, there's no hair anywhere.
It's the swimmers.
Hydrodynamic.
The swimmers?
As in the famous bandits?
I should have known those crooks would play dirty.
Giggles, thank you for the super chat.
Your very first super chat, too.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, I remember wishing you a happy birthday last time.
Just want to say thank you for making my birthday so special
last Thursday.
Here's a little something to show my love and support.
I'm excited for everything you have in the future.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
So it has a single boulder connects with it.
Oh, right.
Oh, yeah.
I remember asking how you guys think the sound was now.
But then I just didn't look at chat.
Oh, shit.
It's 2D time.
Is the sound okay?
Weew.
I can speed run this.
You.
Oh, God.
Whoa.
Oh, I don't know.
Oh, what the fuck?
Where was the where was the fucking?
Assist!
Oh, you guys said it was good?
You're welcome.
Huh?
It's Donkey Kong time.
It's time to beat him up.
Shoot him!
I thought I actually heard Beelzebub talking to me.
Oh, yeah.
Wait, you're right.
It's because our bond grows stronger.
Oh, I had to go this way.
I had to go backwards.
Guys, guys, guys!
It's not a skill.
It's...
aware it's not a shoot it shoot it old man i feel like he's
like in the bathroom like
oh my god it sounds like they're like in the fucking
bathroom right now it like it's throwing me off it's
actually throwing me off no weak knees boys let's go i
thought someone was in my
like in the bathroom the public bathroom guys I haven't like
used my fist in so long I've been using my holy shitty
uppercut in me oh my god bro I haven't how do I dodge oh
it's this okay guys I haven't used my fist in so long I
don't know what that is like using my hands what's that
What the fuck is using my hands like?
I made machines.
The machines have been doing all my work for so long.
What is this like?
Wait, can I combo him?
Can I combo him so he can't do anything?
No, I can't.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Wait, can I send in my...
God, okay, okay, wait, wait, wait.
I have special skills.
Wait, give me a sec.
I have...
Rush!
That's fucking right.
I remember how to dodge guys.
Can't track him.
Guys, I can't see him.
Where is he?
Is he in front of me?
You despicable feed.
Attacking poor defenseless humans.
Cream on.
You're the ones who started this fight.
Oh, yeah, I was like nut level.
How would you like me to finish it?
Guppy?
Why are you calling guppy?
Oh, shit, what about gun?
That's not fair?
Dang it.
Were these just shot his, like, leader?
Oh, it was like a smoke screen.
Oh, that's smart.
I mean, they could have shot him, but like, I guess that
works, too.
If there's one thing they're good at, it's running away.
Alright, nice.
I did it.
Prince, are you unharmed?
You think those losers could take me?
Of course, I'm literally bulletproof.
We've established this.
I saw the whimmers drop in.
wait that's me that's me oh my god he's an artist he's so
beautiful but what would they need this sketch for it's me
yeah hire me i'm cheaper
let me voice act in your game i'm pretty sure i'll be
cheaper because i'm not in oh no that's so fucked up for me
to say Guys, this is a joke, but I was gonna say, I'm not in
the union, so I'm cheaper.
But that's a joke, guys.
I mean, I'm not in union, but, like, I wouldn't, you know,
to take a chance for me.
You've got a gap for drawing, son.
I feel like I've seen this guy somewhere before.
Nah.
All right, shark.
Jesus, cap, shake my head.
Go sell this pick to the news office.
Don't let him have it for any less than two million zennie.
Malcolm dry.
You hear?
What the fuck is wrong with his nose?
He looks like...
He looks...
What the fuck?
Holy shit!
He doesn't need no nose.
I can love...
level up we could still be attacked at any time yay yeah he
looks like fucking bouldermore the prince is here you do
speak sense sometimes thief okay i can level up all right
let's see uh what do i want enhance power boost realize
power really raises power darkness follows boost powers of b
attacks uh boost okay i want boost oh wait already did i
already have boost power of x uh maybe a power of b we did
learn this already let's see follow up i guess we'll try
this and then so we can get rate yeah we can get the max hp
we want that all right what do i want from him his duration
deploy displays near bank his number targets for spoils of
war dropping more items it's gifted with oh i want more
items okay we're just gonna do a thief i feel like the thief
has better you're not able to learn this skill i feel like
the thief has better like abilities passive wise it's all
about the items let's go wait is this death hey guys so
don't so uh welcome back to my playthrough um as you guys
No, do not jump into the sand of death.
Do not do not jump into the sand of death.
Have you tussled with the swimmers before?
Even though they're a bunch of weaklings, they keep picking
fights with me.
Please, if I keep spamming.
Guys, I feel like I should have been using this.
I don't know.
Guys, that's quicksand.
I don't know if you guys know this, but visually, that's
quicksand.
So that's why there's a bridge.
Why did they build a bridge for sand?
Are they stupid?
I'll try that next time.
Let's see.
I want to grab...
Oh, there's some materials down there.
Let's grab that real fast.
Boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop.
Stealing time.
It's not stealing because it's mine.
I don't want to get back up top.
Oh.
Oh, there's stairs here.
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
I was going to say, did I fuck up?
There's stairs here.
Okay, I'm going to just grab the jewels, the gems.
Not the reload.
Hey, reloading.
Just give me infinite ammo.
God off guard puts you at a disadvantage.
Red dog, welcome to tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Wee.
Okay, we're gonna make sure.
We're gonna make sure we reload this too.
Wee.
Is this it?
Wait, did I went the wrong way?
Wait, how do I get there?
Wait, what?
What?
How do I get there?
I'm so...
Is this...
Is there a way downstairs?
Or is that dead end?
Me, thank you for the 10 gift of chips.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, there was a whole...
Down is up, guys.
It took some real damage back there.
Oh, shit.
Sorry, I keep forgetting there's no fault.
It's not this.
Oh, do I have to use, like, the tank?
You have to use the tank.
Yes, I knew it.
I fucking knew it.
When there's a hole, there's a goal.
I don't understand why I don't just like cross out the four
and like rewrite the number.
and tank has been identified as Rao he's alive the 61 year
old sheriff oh he's 61
however when we ran the fingerprints of this sheriff Rao
through a centralized database we discovered a far more
shocking truth Rao was a mere alias this man's Your name
should be familiar to every citizen of this kingdom.
For it belongs to the military genus who became a general of
the Royal Army at the tender age of 27.
Oh my god, that's you.
You were the one that committed war crimes.
The legendary super soldier who protected Sandland from
rebels and outlaws alike.
Fame for his mercy and gentlemanly conduct toward even his
fiercest enemies.
Mercy?
He literally killed off an entire alien race.
renowned general shiva general shiva huh a staggering
development to be sure for general shiva has long been
assumed dead killed by the massive explosion caused when he
protected sandland from the attempted peachy rebellion oh my
god he's like soldier 76 what i did was murder that's what
the s is for s for shiva Teria Shiva that's his wife
You killed your wife Sexy Teria, I love how her name is sexy
Teria Why didn't you tell me that was your wife?
I'm mortified if I'd known I'd never have said Don't worry
about it.
I thought she was sexy too.
That's why I asked her out.
Why is this child?
I thought she was sexy too though.
But if she was your wife, why are magazine clipping?
Good man.
Yeah, where's your personal photos of her?
Oh, that's so sad.
bro he's fucking he puts bro
you can't have private alone happy time in the tank with a
real photo of her he has to fucking make do with a magazine
hunter looked the man is honest at least thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you hang well you're right tell
the news office to double the reward for shefa And to make
an announcement that anyone found sheltering him will be
severely punished Yes, sir Shiva What are you up to?
You explained this you told me we'd gotten rid of Shiva What
the fuck is this baby?
bread thank you for the magenta soup but thank you thank you
random well-being checkup how you been dokey here's 50 do's
get yourself some bread mate maybe some bami too thank you
for the magenta soup but thank you thank you i really
appreciate it i'm doing great playing a nice amazing game
from toriyama bandai with my dragoons your voice down it
looks like a dumpling he does
Is that like his son or something?
Do they have kids?
Must have kids, right?
Whoa.
Oh my god, he's so happy about it.
Oh my god, that gets him.
That makes him a bit way too excited.
I like the tank on the far back, like the one the dot eyes
and he's just like he's just happy to be there i mean he
doesn't even know what he's actually no he doesn't even know
what's going on that tank behind him so what's the plan now
old man wait let me see there's a fast travel that's the
plan here unchanged we find that spring but first i'd like
to swing by one of the radio towers under the army's control
east of here
Why?
I have a message that I'd like as many people as possible to
hear.
Oh my god, he's gonna spread some propaganda.
Let me broadcast what I have to say nationwide.
GoldenHell, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank
you.
That is Kane after too many mortal combats.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Ginger, a grandpa phone diaper, no!
I told you it's just like anime.
my god those are some fucking tanks for to simulate into
don't worry wait who's calling for help right now i like how
like there's an army here and then there's like a guy that's
being fucking um harassed by raptors i'm just gonna run him
over it's not killing if i run him over it's just an
accident
nice is there materials for me Can I simulate into this?
Oh, I can.
Okay, let me kill these raptors real fast.
For them.
There we go.
Muddy!
Oh, there, these kids are still alive.
Phew.
The kids were alive.
It's just a prank.
It's not murder.
Why do people always say murder when you...
I don't understand why people think it's murder when
someone...
simply just dies beside me.
Like, what if they just had a heart attack and I was just
wrong place, wrong time?
Sharko, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I didn't know that Ingoons were in this game.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's only a attempt.
Yeah, it was only an attempt because he survived.
They died.
Yeah, they died.
They could have just had a heart attack.
You don't know that.
Like, they could literally just have a heart attack.
Looks like we're in for a fight.
Okay, we gotta make sure we...
Okay, first off, we have to make sure we hit those.
Alright, nice.
We got this tank.
And then we gotta get that tank.
Alright, they're only level 7.
They're practically like babies.
Okay, then we gotta...
Shoot the people.
You know, my fucking controller aim ain't so bad.
See, look, I did it.
General Ari, the tank squadron at the checkpoint has been
decimated.
Everything I touched eyes, not my fault.
Hey, what?
General Shiva's tank took them out and continued on.
Toki's tank versus coffee.
New measurement.
Who would win?
Oh, shit.
loot loot loot loot loot yeah whoa that's so much stuff for
my new tank just run over it doesn't matter to me prince see
the radio tower on top of that hill yeah that's our target
okay this will be a piece of cake i know it's gonna be so
fucking easy just yet the army must be aware of our general
location oh my god there's my taxi in the area oh it's just
a oh it's just a Uh, do I have anything I need to buy?
I guess I'll buy another repair kit.
I feel like that's the only thing I need.
Yeah!
Wait, there's a base there!
I might as well!
God, I wish I could steal that guy's dinosaur.
It's so much faster than a tank.
Because the heart attacks when they gaze upon you.
So, no, no, no!
It's not my fault they died because I look so fine.
Like, come on.
Is that truly a crime?
Because I look so beautiful that they died of heart attacks.
Like, come on.
It's because they died of pure beauty.
It's not a crime.
So, what are you going to tell everyone?
The truth.
And what's been on my mind.
What's on your mind, old man?
I've got a bad feeling about it.
this beauty is a crime we should keep our distance from the
army base unless necessary I bet they've got loads of loot
in there I know they have so much loot that but somehow I
doubt they'd take kindly to intruders I'm gonna not listen
to him we'll run up out of it please at least try to be
sneaky about it sensei thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you do i have to be sneaky i'm gonna pretend i
didn't hear what he said i'm gonna go straight in or the
terrain's to your disadvantage keep moving until you're in a
better spot no i don't need a move that won't stop me
exactly look at that I run away.
I can't level up, you idiot.
God, oh man, it's all about the lovers.
Okay.
I almost got it.
Oh, nice.
See, look at that.
Nothing to worry about.
Oh, shit.
Okay, I didn't miss.
There we go.
And then I told you guys.
See, nothing to worry about.
Who needs stealth?
Who needs stealth when I have all this fucking loot?
Oh, I can rob them, too.
Give me a sec.
We're going to go to the base and rob them.
Give me a sec, guys.
This is very important.
Wee.
There should be nobody here anymore, because I didn't kill
them.
They ran away.
Yes.
Got more loot.
Loot, loot, loot, loot, loot.
Why would I run away when I know I'm better?
Are there royal army soldiers all over Sandland?
There's even a bunch near our village.
Most of them are stationed near the royal capital.
It can be a lot more hit and miss the farther you get away
with it.
No, I can't.
You'll also see supply units traveling around as they
transport goods to bases.
Those are probably the ones who pass near our village.
Alright.
Nice.
Look at how the loot I got.
listen to him.
Wait, can I beat this?
Ugh, there we go.
If I had listened to him, I wouldn't have got all this good
loot.
How do I get up there, though?
I should grab the tank.
Loot, loot, loot.
Stealth is for the weak.
Exactly!
Here we go.
Stealth is for people who are weak and don't know how to...
And know they can't beat them up by pure strength.
From the army.
At least that was sort of fun.
Stealth is for cowards.
Don't, yeah, this is why you don't listen to Elder.
They don't know what's good for you.
Your information is outdated.
It's because this old man is so fucking weak.
So that's why he was not confident in beating the army up.
Let me grab this.
Oh my god, I can have a dino!
Alright guys.
What do you think about stopping by that campsite?
They're using ourselves.
This is my.
This is better.
That's open to all travelers.
Like, what do I do with the camp?
Anyway.
Like, I don't need a rest because I never get off the...
I never get off the fucking tank.
Finally.
Riding my true...
riding my true vehicle the guy they give us super chat thank
you thank you really appreciate it
let's see uh bear think of us super chat thank you thank you
you cause a heart attack when they gazed upon you so murder
they give us super chat thank you thank you they could look
away just close your eyes how do you get murdered just close
your eyes no Hey, Rao, we've been spotted.
Wait, he has a shield.
Does the shield actually stop a fucking cannon shot?
But we can still take them.
Hold up.
Looks like they've got us around it.
They do?
Wait, who's that?
Wait, oh, that's the general.
General Ace.
What do we do?
We're shitting ducks out here Watch your rear Biel's thief
you ready for this Like you have to ask How many times must
I tell you to address him as prince Bielzebub?
Okay, I'm curious if this stops the fuck okay, it does not I
was gonna say like how the fuck is like?
How the fuck does the fucking?
stop a cannon it's actually like that's very oh that's my
guy sorry i actually stopped i actually shot ralph whoops my
bad my bad that was ralph guys i'm sorry he needs to like
paint his color he needs to paint his tank a different color
man thank you for the super chat thank you thank you vtubers
are so cute i think it's like cute god i wish women were
real i know man it's too bad we're it's too bad vtubers
aren't real and women aren't real either we're all just ai
looks like they disabled it in advance to keep us from using
it they read us like a book This commander is a pro.
So you're saying this was all for nothing?
No, I think we can get it fixed.
We all know women on the internet aren't real.
It's all just men with voice changes.
Can I repair it?
I have so much materials.
Yeah, I was going to say, I've fucking been like scavenging
for so long.
There's no way I don't have materials.
Am I a man?
Yes, we're all...
Women aren't real on the internet, guys.
This is Shiva.
Former General Shiva.
I have something I want to tell the people of this country.
If you'll let me transmit it.
Yes.
Right away, please.
We have just received radio contact from a man claiming to
be General Shiva himself.
What?
He has a message for you all.
And while we have not been able to confirm his identity, we
have agreed to transmit his words live on our...
Don't worry, I'll always be your bro.
I'm actually surprised they let them trans...
Like, let them transmit their his message.
First, allow me to sincerely apologize to you all for any
distress I may have caused.
Units, cut the engines!
Make it quiet!
confess to the crime of stealing a tank but unlike what you
were told previously i have not attacked any villages with
it i swear this on my life yeah i'm brokey bird i'll always
be a bro spread panic and confusion amid this country i
intend only to find a legendary spring which i assure you is
no mere fairy tale for this country cannot withstand any
more drought spring did he say spring what is he even
talking about so please just allow me to finish this mission
without interference when i find the spring i promise to
make its location public okay but like is this like the only
spring in the whole fucking world wouldn't that be like I
feel like the spring will get like quickly depleted because
humans are greedy there's no way the spring is gonna feed
the entire population in sad land person on an entirely
different subject
though this doesn't absolve my role in causing that
explosion 30 years ago I've learned the truth behind it yeah
it would dry up in like a week wouldn't it it could be a
legendary spring oh my god just say it mr sheba a question
if you were why didn't you just fucking call him out i'd
call him out i'd be like bro guys by the way i sort of
committed like an extreme war crime because like i didn't
save you guys and we actually wiped off the only race that
was gonna give us free water fuck you general name is
because i already forgot you're that irrelevant to me
contact the news office immediately tell them that they are
never to allow that criminal to speak freely on air again
this is bad isn't it say you he said something about the
truth behind that explosion why didn't he just reveal it
this was the only time he's ever gonna be allowed in the air
like he should have just revealed everything looking for do
you think what he's really referring to is our secret water
source oh this is bad very very bad you don't want to
slander anyone do he literally said i will never forgive you
commander zoo i'm sorry for dragging you two into this all
right Let's keep heading south They're just gonna censor him
now Alright Alright I feel like I can upgrade my tank now
for now Right?
I have so much materials I have so much mats I must be able
to Alright better Dragoon What do you need baby?
Better Dragoon Okay better Dragoon doesn't need anything
He's already better Your vehicle is too low level?
Oh my!
This is why you're Dragoon...
This is why you're Dragoon 1.
Let's see.
You're too low level for even upgrades.
I need...
Neglected again.
He's already perfect.
Can I just jump down?
Okay, look.
I know we learned that we can't, but like, what if I...
Wait, can I just fast travel?
Oh, no, it's like right over here.
But what if I, like, watch this.
It's going to be like, I'm going to Skyrim this.
There.
That's why you know I'm a gamer.
That's why you guys watch me.
You know other VTubers won't do this.
I make my own pathways.
I don't follow what society tells me to.
Does that mean...
No one...
Supreme Commander Zayu, sir.
Yes, sir.
I believe General...
Shiva is very close.
Not like I think, girl.
A mere ghost requires no title.
Don't even try to capture him alive.
Understand?
Kill him.
Once and for all.
Kill him war.
Okay, well, I was going to say war hero slash criminal.
Forgive me.
But might I ask you just one thing, Supreme Commander?
What jet?
Shiva said about the truth behind that explosion.
You see, my own father was killed in that explosion.
So...
His father was killed in that explosion.
Wait, what if he's like secretly the son?
Is he like...
Is this guy 30?
My apologies.
He has daddy and shoes and the other guy's a dad he you
don't don't fall for it he's just pretending to be some
selfless goody two shoes you can't trust people like that
though if there's one thing we can agree on is that say
who's a damn rat all right come on guppy I'm right at the
midpoint between Shiva and the royal army.
Got it, Papa.
There's so many dads.
It's like the first bomb in Fallout.
Enemy tank brigade.
Oh my god!
They started it!
What?
They're like Voltec.
Prepare to engage.
hurry they shot first dad land
love how each tank has like different eyes war never changes
take cover behind the rocks and swing around in the other
direction to attack them wait which which rock whoa which
rock though
There's so many rocks!
Wait, is this mine?
This is mine.
Sorry.
I couldn't tell.
Wait, where's the other tank?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
That's the other tank.
Oh, shit.
He also missed.
Back into positions.
Nice.
Is that it?
That's okay.
He's okay.
My tank's okay.
a fight like that must have been a piece of cake for you
prince i know pretty badass huh hold on that was way too
easy yeah where's the commander
whoa there he is wait why does his take it to be a different
color
fair if i kill the commander do i win this battle won't end
take him out oh my god i'm so oh it won't end i actually
have to take him out where's the blind spot where did he go
oh shit okay did i hit him all right if i go up here he
can't get me that's not him all right he can't hit me from
here oh shit guys oh my god thank god i like i repaired a
tap route shoot your son it's okay this might be like your
very last like remaining relative because you killed your
wife as well but you might as well kill your son you know
double whammy the cube's water is too expensive for most
people to even afford the bare minimum to survive so i
promised my village that i would find Oh my god, he does so
much damage.
What the fuck?
Unbelievable.
He's super human.
What do you mean he?
I did majority of the work.
He disabled our unit with zero loss of life.
He's exactly the man my father said he was.
I can't hope to compete.
He's on a whole different plane.
Oh, his father said he was?
Oh, so that means he was...
That's not the son, then.
Because he's like, oh, my father said he was...
So he actually, like, talked to his dad.
Well, I did so...
I finished it so fast that we even get to hear 50% of that
dialogue.
Despite not answering your question, I have one for you.
On the radio, you mentioned the truth behind the explosion
30 years ago.
What is it?
You may not want to hear it.
I believe it, but I've got no hard proof.
I, Amare, the son of Apoe, one of your very own officers.
Please, tell me.
I need to know the truth of my father's death.
Apoe's son, eh?
I see.
Very well, then.
Who's Apoe?
thief you're our source he should hear it from you
you've got to be must i do everything around here bro all
you do is sit around don't tell me you heard this story from
him yeah he's the demon you take the word of a demon that
doesn't kill if you won't listen to what he has to say i
can't force you but let me say this world i admit anyone as
honest as these two that's like
that's so fucked up like because they're like fucking demons
like like what kind of they might as well be like they might
as well just not be demons at that point i trust them far
far more than any human at least like what the fuck is the
point of having demons if you're not more evil how our fear
and suspicion of the peachy demons should be like the
benchmark of evil not the fucking middle like
yeah he means humans are worse we're at the point where like
humans are worse than demons
what's happening in this game it's so confusing we're in a
land filled with sand and there's tanks and we're trying to
find water because it's all sand the end guppy do your thing
turn every last one of them into fertilizer with that cannon
of yours that bounty's as good as ours
damn it what the fuck what you can do that why can't do that
in game no don't tell me there was another tank no it came
from somewhere above us i'll hop up high and look around
don't worry it's parkour time i can't believe the humans are
worse than demons now like what's the point of being a demon
might as well be a human like they already fucking took our
jobs the humans took our fucking jobs it's the swimmers
those little oh he's gonna swear beelzebub spotted us time
to split dang it they got away again i'm gonna pulverize
them next time that beelzebub just saved our lives as any
demon would do Perhaps it's true that we've misjudged the
demons.
Alright, I'll hear it.
Tell me the story of what caused the explosion 30 years ago,
thief.
Nope.
Not till I hear the magic word.
Please?
What?
You little imp?
Who do you think you're...
Silence you!
Meow.
Please just tell me Please That's so attractive All right
Please Please sir Tell me please I'm baking you on my knees
Please Please It's possible No Surely that can't be true
Please Don't keep please No commander say was a cold man but
i can't believe he could be so inhuman well we've set our
peace and sorry but it looks like we'll have to borrow the
tank a bit longer
sir are you sure should we really be letting shiva go like
this yes we trust him what do you mean by that we never had
him to begin bro they he literally we literally beat the
shitter of him and he hadn't even finished his dialogue he
didn't even finish his plot we almost did until the swimmers
struck out of nowhere that is they took out our tanks then
fled that is what happened isn't it sir yes sir my god he's
gonna lie no guess I should make my report to Supreme
Commander Zayu no there's something I have to confirm with
the King
use oh my god finally to pick well i was gonna say why can i
do that yeah why how did i fucking suddenly realize i
learned how to throw rocks i feel like i should know how to
throw rocks originally i've been living in the sand for so
long use rb and then pick b to pick up a problem ground in
terms of one the throw mode okay yay we can head south let's
go time to head south they're already here that was easy we
did it i'm stronger now oh you're right i leveled up i guess
everywhere you look one wrong step and you'll be swallowed
up don't worry i'm light of the feather okay we started to
prove that that was not true
bro he forgot that we drowned in the sand water
anyway we can't proceed south unless we figure out how to
get We're gonna get water dragons.
How are we supposed to do that?
Even the prince- We're gonna be like a dragon boat!
None of our bots will help either.
The tank or jump bot would only be even worse off.
It didn't happen in the cutscene.
Doesn't count.
So true.
It'd be easy if we could just fly over it.
But with planes outlawed.
Yeah, but how would they know?
How would they know that?
What if we just, you know, ran really fast?
Oh, I like those geckos that can run on water.
Explain, please.
it kind of felt like i was sinking more slowly while i was
running aha cross before sinking to the point of no return
hey prince thief let's head back to spino let me guess and
to the rescue again what's wrong with letting add help it's
because oh my god he's fucking sexist because she's a woman
isn't she all right let's see spino where's spino why is he
so against having ad help us she's like like one other like
three women we met here oh my god wait let's see where the
is spino oh there it is i was like we're spino the giant
checkpoint right there there's like three women in in the in
sandland closing up shop already
yeah there's someone i have to meet right now someone from
the royal army or maybe the news office why would you think
that ever since the warning about oh my god she's gonna rat
us out for money i'm sure you figured out who we are by now
you saw right through me whoa whoa whoa so you were planning
on ratting us out how dare she after everything we've been
through danger by letting you people stay here your concerns
are justified we don't intend to cause you good people any
trouble we promise to never come back now we have two women
left in sandland please allow anne to keep staying here
she's a personal guest of mayor tours and had no part in the
theft what do you mean you people well in that fine hold on
we all busted out of the base in that tank to get Prince
thief let's go this is our only home miss that garage it was
like our secret I even got chance to customize this town I
got 50 chairs what am I gonna do with 50 chairs mayor tour
80s don't you know what these people are doing they've been
trying to find a spring and not just for their own personal
benefit mind you they're trying to help everyone yeah all
five people in this town sorry four soon after ad's gone so
to add a this is after a this is gone too probably but i
can't stand by as the people of this nation suffer any
longer even if it means putting your life at risk that is
not my name anymore yeah it's raura raura raura it's this
warm i'm pretty sure in japanese it sounds a lot better in
english it's so hard to pronounce you heard the man how
about this 80s this is a toriama style game it's the last
game toriama was involved in perhaps we should hear from the
entire town before making our final decision i'm sure each
resident has their own thoughts on the matter you're right
this wasn't something for me to decide to be fair 30 million
yen i would turn myself into not 30 million yen 30 many
million zen i love how it's like called zen instead of yen
hello Oh my god, two of the four villages.
Hey, you're with Rao, right?
Aren't you leaving with him?
I was considering it, but they shot me down.
Oh, Diki 12 might be the last one.
What gives?
Talk about harsh.
Right?
I know they're just trying to protect me, but it still
hurts.
It's frustrating.
But part of me is happy to know how much they care.
So, I've decided to do...
what i can by looking after this place that way they'll
always have somewhere to go back to sorry if that's not what
you wanted to hear uh you sound like one of their crew all
right in a good way oh sorry we gave you the wrong idea we
wanted to tease you for a bit but we're not here to chase
you out we'll be happy to have you here oh my god she's
getting welcomed in the community Yeah.
Oh, they don't know.
We'll know they're isolating her already.
We've not met anyone as good-hearted as you guys.
Though BLs would hate being called that.
Whoa!
That he would.
I like how we're like, yeah, we're eavesdropping.
So anyway, we're glad you'll be standing guard at the
garage.
And stay put.
Leave convincing the villagers to us.
You've got it.
It's good.
It's only two other villagers.
have to wait for a bit but we owe her an apology as we stand
in front of her you might have to wait for a bit but we owe
her an apology i like how we like just just listen to it in
front of her 80s fuck you 80s is it true that you want to
report shiva yeah how dare you how else am i gonna look at
that hot lady working on cars yeah that's right I would have
done it too if mayor It wasn't for those meddling kids And
he was right too We won't submit to the royal army's threats
Even if it kills us Oh are you still carping about that The
civil wars long since over For 30 years Exile her She wants
to get rid of And The royal army is still the same bunch of
jackbooted thugs they were back then.
And I won't stop fighting until that changes.
Good grief.
Once his temper flares, all you can do is wait for him to
cool down on his own.
Just leave him be.
That said, I don't think we should report General Shiva
either.
He may have been our enemy in the past, but he and he's
honest.
He's reformed.
He's old.
He's like 60.
What's he gonna do?
We can push him If the elderly starts acting up just push
them I trust him Don't push the elderly in real life guys.
Don't don't listen to Doki advice.
Sometimes they might be bad If he takes the royals down a
peg in the process, I can die happy Hold on.
Do you still hate the royal army?
then you have to ask like i'd ever forgive them for leaving
my hometown in ruins i think i know where i stand now but
jia's like 60 yes he's 60 but he's still a saiyan he's not a
real person like i mean sorry he's not he's not a human he's
still he's like that's like in like
Are they all talking without me?
Oh, he's crying.
Why are you crying?
What's wrong, Flika?
Did you wet the bed again or something?
No.
It's just that everyone in town seems mad and I'm scared.
Forgive me.
I'm afraid that's all my fault.
Oh my God.
For once, I can actually talk in this conversation.
Instead of eavesdropping.
It's more like I'm what they're all fighting over.
Betty, but she doesn't real.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Are you guys...
To be fair, the Saiyans, we're sort of like...
Didn't really have rights for a very long time.
That's what we're all trying to decide.
To be fair.
But I don't want your BL's above to go.
Maybe you should tell everyone that.
okay she's a good kid it's thanks to all of you that she
could grow up to be so kind and carefree hmm but i suppose
you could say it takes a village huh we don't want to
disturb the community you've built here flea considers all
of you a part of that community too you know this cruel
world only ever seems to take more and more away from us
that's why the rare gifts
I bought the deluxe versions for the chairs.
I think we've heard enough.
I got 50 chairs and 50 windows apparently.
Can I start customizing this goddamn town?
It seems we have our verdict now.
Seems like it.
Who knew hatred for the royal army army ran so deep not deep
enough for 80s apparently when that came out wrong see there
are others who support your cause
sounds like we've really got to find that spring now guess
so alright we gotta find water can I talk to you now hey
Anne you gotta build us the fastest ride ever I'm fine,
thanks for asking.
Sounds fun, but I need the deets.
You see, some intense quicksand is blocking our path south
of here.
We need something that can zip across it before it sinks.
Well, can't you use your car?
It's too slow.
The sand would swallow it up.
We need something faster!
Hmm.
Maybe my bike might work your bike too bad.
I don't have it.
Wait what happened to this.
Oh, yeah, we lost we lost a bike It got wrecked during my
whole high-speed chase with the Royal Army back in Talbot.
It's a bike faster than water sand Couldn't you fix it if
you had one of those core frame watch it's yeah Sure, but I
haven't recovered that from the wreck.
We'll have to go get it then that's what we'll do where is
it yeah where is it i was pretty focused on just getting
away so i've only got a rough idea i know it should be
somewhere north of talbo at least how specific but i think
i'll be able to remember more once we get closer good let's
go together sorry i didn't quite catch that what did you say
we're gonna go together i said let's go together yeah you're
not dead weight so you do that has to be a key for something
that looks like the most key thing in the world like it has
to be a fucking key
oh hush let's get going already
all right let's see we gotta find the bike oh i gotta
customize yeah yeah yeah we gotta upgrade our parts okay
parts make part can i like customize my weapon let's see but
like uh i don't know if like my stuff is stronger that's the
thing i don't remember what my parts were
Wait, did I install it?
My tank too low still?
Your level is still too low?
I need to upgrade my vehicle?
Oh my god, how much...
What level does this vehicle need?
Customized vehicle?
Yes.
I need to level up you.
Okay, level up vehicle.
Upgrade vehicle.
Alright, Dragoon 1.
It's time to get upgraded.
Are you strong enough now?
You have to be.
I wasted so many mats on you.
Okay, parts.
Upgrade part.
Can you...
Oh, thank God!
Okay.
I can upgrade you, right?
No, I don't...
God damn it.
I don't...
I can't even upgrade you anymore.
Oh, wait.
Is that better?
28.
Yeah.
Okay.
Can I upgrade you?
God damn it!
Where the...
What the fuck is Crocs?
What's Crocsteer?
Okay, let's see.
We're gonna upgrade you.
Upgrade.
And then...
Yeah, but what is it?
See you later.
I think that's all the parts.
I'm pretty sure.
Is it?
Is there anything else?
Whoa.
We gotta sell some parts, though.
We're like...
Uh...
Yeah, I think that's everything.
Alright.
Wee.
See.
Is that, like, quest?
Like, a mini quest right here?
What is this?
Hello.
80s.
Welcome back.
That merchant told me he was saved by a demon on his way
here.
That was you.
That was me.
It was.
Let me thank you too.
You truly are a lifesaver.
I don't know what you're talking about.
A lifesaver that you're gonna ride out.
Can't you just let her think?
Yeah, silence you rat.
Oh, new items?
Okay, never mind.
Everything that I said about you, I was just joking.
I was just joking.
He-he.
Adhesive, clay.
Oh, these are just...
What about Kroxia?
You have Kroxia?
Can I, like, sell my materials?
Or parts?
Oh, there we go.
Okay.
Guys, I actually forgot which ones are the ones I don't
need.
I wish, like, I don't remember!
I don't remember!
Okay, we're just gonna...
I don't remember which one I want to sell, so we're just
gonna hoard it, I guess.
No, thank you for the...
give the ships thank you thank you all right i already
forgot which one i have to sell so i'm just gonna we're just
gonna hoard everything might as well we don't need the money
anyway i feel like we farm so much that we don't even need
the money i think we'll be fine all right time to ride my
dono okay i'm gonna ride the done i'm gonna steal the dino
and then i'm gonna use the bathroom I'll be back, guys.
I'm
back.
I have to kick out.
I have to kick out Doki Ambridoge real quick.
Because he, like, sneaked into my room.
Evan, Meddy, and Ari, and Gladstone.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, it's this way.
Wait, is there a fast travel for this?
This has to be a fast travel, right?
Yeah.
Ginger, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
dinos feed up the cow wait i can feed up the cows now no the
cows take that that's looking right leave leave this town
leave you're a general in the royal army right now this town
has no food anymore you're welcome you can erase the past
nor would it be right to do so i have to live with
scorpions leave if you know what's good for you oh my god
they like died so fast
like i interrupted her well obviously that's not fucking
that's not the croc steel i need be gone silly cows
now this town will not have any food anymore you're welcome
how could you toky oh shit i can farm cactuses oh that's
nice to know whose car is this it was the only way i could
live with wait oh that's a bad oh shit that's a bad car all
right that was a car that was a car he was just doing some
fucking sick drifts and i like interrupted him
all right these guys who are slowly running towards me these
were guys that were slowly running towards me sounds tough
this is my home now things are better now
Nice.
Now I get to rob them.
What kind of region are we in?
Well, there should be a few towns, an army base, and a
bandit hideout around here.
Oh, there's a radio tower.
Soldiers and bandits.
Now he's drifting in heaven.
I interrupted their fucking drift session.
It's okay.
That raptor can join another family.
I was kind of focused on escaping.
I killed him in the cutscene.
I know it's around here somewhere.
Maybe the royals claimed it after they arrested you.
Look, they're the invasive species.
These raptors?
Oh my god!
He took it!
Terrano seemed to be carrying something in its mouth.
Speaking of which, heard that terra knows build their nests
out of metal oh they like harvested a bike then maybe one of
them took my bike it's middle gear it's quite possible then
we should go after it it's already out of sight not to worry
they like to nest on rocky cliffs just like these let's head
after it and see if we can find a way up those cliffs here
we go is very sensitive to movement and shiny that's okay I
know parkour it only takes the slightest stimulation to draw
their attention if only it was so easy to get the prince to
pay attention wait what is that supposed to mean I pay
attention okay guys I might need some assistance
now watch this okay how is I supposed to know I'd be too
short.
How the fuck was I supposed to know that?
Terranos are especially ordinary this time of year.
Whatever you do, don't provoke them.
I'm gonna provoke them.
Watch this.
Pew!
I'm gonna shoot them out of the sky.
Nice.
I told you.
Man, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Your very first super.
Thank you again.
Alright.
Up I go.
What is that item?
Wait, that's loot.
An egg.
The inside of the shell is still all gooey.
is she like must have hatched recently oh i was gonna say
did she like harvest somebody's fucking egg i was gonna be
like that's so up and
all right up we go i can't believe it what it's free too
Oh, we fixed a we fixed a pterodactyl population a
pterodactyl population Yeah, oh, there it is there's the
eggs Wonder where the babies went Mildly impressed they were
able to build a nest out of this junk Pretty ingenious
indeed There's more loot More to the point I wonder if
they've left any rare parts behind I'm gonna make this jump
we I knew I would make it oh my god look at all these
fucking free shit I love free shit check I just need croc
steel I have no I still have no idea what's which one's croc
steel okay all right we need a swap to we need a swap to a
tank oh that's nice that I just Swap to, like, you don't
have to get off and swap that way.
That's so convenient.
That's your bike.
How the fuck did you get rusted so fast?
It's like two days.
It's like two to three days.
But Prince, wait.
Oh, shit.
I didn't kill you.
kids i swear they just grew up and flew away from the nest i
swear to god we've got no chance about running something
like that then there's only one option left i
swear i didn't do anything to your kids oh god breathing
fire i mean to fear everything it's red i would assume it
breathes fire just saw like how blue breathes ice and yellow
breathes electricity whoa he's off fucking oh shit get him
while he's down get him while he's down shoot him in the
dick oh shit oh whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
there you go I think I did it
now run on that I run him over with the tank i'm gonna need
some parts for the repairs but if scrappy do can
the whole plot of velma season two is a scrappy do bit off
people's Dicks that I can shoot somebody in the dick
Come at me with all you got then wait wait wait wait about
what oh now you don't care about at animals Now you condone
animal cruelty.
Oh It's like the eggs Don't worry those aren't what we're
after He's telling the truth.
We just want my motorcycle back
He's like I can understand
Let's get out of here already quick before he's like I see
okay
Good point
Negotiators wait I got the wings how the fuck did I get the
wings if like i didn't kill how do you think about it like
that doesn't make sense i didn't get though how would i grab
a piece of their wing here is done now i just need the right
parts as per usual they grew up oh yeah you're right they
grew back it's my bike i could rebuild that thing in my
sleep no kidding all righty then
all right i think i oh i can level up now all right what do
i want to okay what is this raise i want a max hp and then
increase potency raises beasables attack when increase
deployment speed for abysmal specific items boost powers of
be i might as oh wait i don't have enough low oh i have two
oh i have one more okay uh maybe the rush oh i already did
that uh oh i need three for that oh okay i'm just gonna save
up then uh detect hidden items okay we need that we need the
hidden item shit okay there's a chance of enemy dropping
rare parts hell yeah i need more crocs dia we don't care
about the old man i need all the loot do you need anything I
need to make parts apparently Or the bike What the fuck
cares about the car Okay the bike Oh my god I can put a
cannon on the bike Let's go Alright nice and in suspension
Yeah I'm not gonna build the car I don't care about the car
that much Um
Can I do this?
Okay, make a vehicle.
Okay, motorbike.
Hoop, poop, poop, poop.
And then...
Okay.
Make it.
Wait, do I not have enough money?
I don't have enough money?
I need to pay you to make your own bike?
What?
Okay, I got...
I get it.
I'm broke.
I gotta sell some stuff.
Welcome.
Alright, give me a sec.
I gotta sell something.
I can't believe I have to pay her.
That's so bullshit.
Okay, 77.
I'm just gonna sell this.
Thank you for coming.
Well, I don't know.
I thought I had a lot of money too.
I don't know.
God damn it.
This is your own bike.
You should fucking...
You should...
Not gonna lie, but she should actually, like, you know...
Actually help out.
I don't have raptors, you know?
Bro, you should chip in.
It's your fucking bike.
It's literally hers.
I have to kill some raptors real quick, guys.
Like, apparently, I don't have enough Raptor Steel to put
this together.
How is she gonna get parts about money?
This is so bullshit!
That's a kill some more babies!
Oh my god, if I could, I would fucking...
I would knock out the merchant and then...
I'll knock out the merchant and farm his raptor is that
fucked up goodbye goodbye little guy
our bodies can't digest a lot of it's a green raptor that
are down right well so it goes oh my god it's like a mirror
cat all right i did it no green yeah Wait, I don't want the
green scale.
I need the red one, right?
Wait, I need the red one.
My god, I killed the family for no reason!
It's not even the right raptor!
Where the fuck is the red one?
Oh, there they are.
Okay, there's the red ones.
The old man.
Yeah.
Alright.
Well, I just...
They're like Miracat's.
Like Miracat Raptors.
Knowing what they can do and what their weaknesses are will
help you fight effectively.
They don't...
They're all weak to the fucking missiles.
That's all I need to know.
Try that.
Well, so it goes.
That's all I need.
I like how the range for this is so low.
Alright, this has to be the Raptor Stealer, right?
The Raptor Scale?
Oh my god, finally.
Okay, we're going back.
We did it.
I got the right family.
We've harvested the right family.
Do you need any?
Yes, please make the vehicle.
We're going to make your own bike.
Wait, is Raptor Steel?
scale oh my god how do I get raptor steel oh my god this
fucking sucks well my literacy got the better of me again do
you sell raptor steel you don't even sell raptor skia i
can't believe it through a side quest which one i think so
many oh my god all right guys i gotta go fucking do a side
quest i have to craft it all right we're gonna figure out
which side quest was the crafting one um I have, okay, is it
the Commander Ardia?
The, wait, what?
Okay, which one is Water Supply Point Gifted Flowers?
Which one's our quest?
Junker Market.
Okay, the junk pit.
Is it the junk pit?
Let's see.
Can I fast travel this?
I can, thank God.
Okay.
Uh.
All right, get in here.
It's not that?
Oh my god.
Okay, where's my quest log?
Okay, which one?
All right, these are the quests I completed.
All right.
Okay, there's the junk pit.
Okay, I completed these.
All right.
Oh, guys, I just realized there's not a lot.
I only have one side quest, apparently.
Wait, where is this one?
How do I get there?
Oh, it's this way.
It's this way?
Am I heading the right way?
No, it's this way.
Guys, I got lost again.
Well, I might as well farm these fucking scorpion scales.
I don't know which one is, like, the quest for crafting.
What does the crafting quest come?
chat oh wait i need to uh we need to swap okay and then jump
what i'm not i can't jump high enough what's the point
what's the point of having a bot that's literally for
jumping when i can't even jump high enough that's actually
crazy oh i need to go to the junker all right i'm done with
this quest.
No, I can't fast travel because the animals are angry at me.
What did I do?
Rock, paper, scissors, me for it.
Alright, let me finish this quest first, I guess.
Rock, paper, scissors.
Yay!
I win!
This has to be the quest.
I'll get you next time.
Are they evil people?
Oh, no.
Hey, Ren.
You want to talk?
Oh,
you're an NPC.
You don't matter.
I know we've come all the way to this scrap pit.
It all don't matter.
Wee!
Oh!
Nice.
Lady looks a fan of mine.
Not nice.
Get in the cat.
Oh, there we go.
Get in the tank.
So easy
So fucking easy guys I'm stuck With just a few more parts
You could actually make a whole car Let me get off Oh no
Let's try asking no Oh, no.
Guys, we have a little problem.
Alright, nice.
Okay, we got off.
Oh, thank God.
I was a little worried.
Ooh, extra armor.
Ooh, B-grade gunpowder.
I forgot to fuel efficiency.
We don't need that.
That shit's for losers.
Okay, we won't.
open that already?
How do we get out of here?
Oh, there's stairs.
I could have used the stairs.
Nice.
I'm assuming we jumped this way, right?
Here we go.
This way?
We'll rock.
okay we always need more ores ores are good for us i still
can't believe i have to fucking make her goddamn bike
poop poop is there raptor steel ma'am is there any raptor
steel i can scavenge here we go please would anyone i would
sure it's multiplayer so like i can just ask a dragon to
trade me some raptor seal
that'll be the life
that's all i want is it this oh raptor still finally who the
fuck is corrupta okay that is we need four right oh my god
thank god now there's a quest here too
can you do me a huge favor and get me something sure huh no
way please my boss will kill me if i don't get 10 pieces of
iron ore oh i have 10 pieces then i've tried i promise i was
mining for it
I have iron ore.
It was really good.
I completely lost track of the time.
Is the comic really that good?
You like comics?
I'll let you read it if you bring me the ore.
Oh my god, the comics survived?
There's no trees anywhere.
Wait, yeah, it's sand.
Oh, alright.
Sure.
You're the best.
Thanks, buddy.
I already have it.
might as well like i already yeah it's literally here thanks
you're a lifesaver the boss i did your favor can i see the
comic now yeah what's the comic oh yeah sure how good is
this how good is the comic i don't even get to see it i gave
him 10 ore oh and here's the thing i promised
thanks i can never have too many of these so bring some over
if you have any despair i'll repay you of course and stock
up on some new comics too oh my god i can't believe it i
didn't even i lost 10 ore what did i gain from that it just
says i lost 10 ore that's it did i got scammed like have you
heard a sandpaper at the thank you with a super chat thank
you thank you yeah but doesn't that like that's like super
fucking though I can't believe it he took that he took that
and like left me okay we have the craft I had to pay him for
the craft no I didn't okay thank God okay I was gonna say I
was gonna be so sad about to pay him as well because like
I'm already broke all right I completed the quest old man
now give me your money I'm broke this girl's gonna take all
money soon car frame you bet we did but we need more parts
to build our car have any idea where we can nab some i'm
afraid i can't help as far as parts go but i'm sure you'll
come across some sooner or later you gain valuable
experience in not getting scammed miracle thank you the
super chat thank you thank you guys will she learn her
lesson and not get scammed Don't find out next time
Sandland.
I'll think about it.
Alright.
Here is...
Alright, time to make her fucking bike now.
I should have enough now, right?
Okay.
My new car.
There we go.
Good is new.
No, this is not a dragon this is a straight-up scam all
right nice wow i got 500 nice okay all right now we can now
we can leave oh yeah i should save the game you're right
guys whoa whoa there's a reason why we don't save i'm so
sorry i'm so sorry i'm so sorry
I'm sorry, guys.
Whoa.
That was crazy.
Okay, now we go here?
Yeah.
Water supply point.
Uh, now we can, like, ride the water.
Here we go.
Alright, autopilot, leave vehicle, boost, shoot, aim,
reload.
Oh, I have drift!
I can drift now, too.
Okay.
oh my god drifting time it's good to wander off the beaten
path speed up before we sink into the sand I am speeding I'm
going so fucking fast you don't understand grandpa gas gas
gas dang thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
for scam recovery fun he could ride through the sand with
his car.
Papa, Beelzebub's here.
Oh, right.
Are you ready for action, Gupy?
We're getting that bounty for sure this time.
Here goes.
I feel like Gupy eats all the food for these kids.
Bro, okay, somebody should, like, take the gun away from
Gupy.
Oh, he actually hit.
Did you get him?
That's like the first time I saw Guppie hit anything.
Also, he fucking shot my car that I spent so much money on.
I'm so mad.
I just made it.
More or less.
What the heck just happened?
Those idiots apparently still haven't learned.
Yoshi, welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
The feed prince.
Ow.
Beelzebub's still alive and kicking!
Say what?
Zua, does he look mad?
Very.
He's glaring right at us.
You two, take care of my ride.
And you?
I'm gonna beat up some old men.
Yeah, that's the PG way of saying it.
Get over here.
Don't worry.
Doki mad.
Here I'll go.
You're up against the biggest, baddest criminals in
Sandland.
Here I go.
Oh, wrong guy Wait, I did that much damage?
Are you serious?
I like the damage damage?
Oh shit, that's fucked up.
Where is he shooting at?
Oh my god, okay guys, a guppy needs like help.
At this point, this might be a guppy issue.
Like...
Oh shit!
Ow.
Wait, but he does so little damage.
I'm not scared.
Whoa!
Wait, that did nothing.
Wait, that's funny.
That actually did nothing.
Okay, let's get rid of this child first.
I feel like I should just get rid of Swimmer Papa.
Okay.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Where are you?
Don't you dare dodge me.
That's right.
I'm going to punch you in the dick because I'm at the
perfect height.
Oh shit.
Honestly, I don't think there's like any point in like
beating up the children as well.
Because like...
What the...
Wait, he doesn't...
What?
He doesn't even notify me!
Oh shit.
Because I just need to kill him.
It's okay.
Got it.
Dodge him.
Oh, I did not dodge him.
Okay, nice.
Keep dodging.
That's fucking right.
He just runs.
Do you believe that sling actually exists?
Oh, he is pissed.
Can't see.
That's for my bike.
I just spent money on it, too.
But what I do believe in is the old man.
If he says there's a spring, I bet he's right.
I met this guy like a week ago.
If, and I mean if you fight it, would you maybe let us swim
there too?
Oh, that's why they're called the swimmer gang.
I love on the far left you can see the guppy's ass.
We might call a nice view.
But my sons never got the chance to kick up somebody noticed
it before I did that's for sure Do what you like Just one
left Wait, who's the one left?
Oh, the guy that's running?
What the fuck
It's like freaking guys It's anime Sonic now.
Oh shit.
Oh no.
It's okay.
I'm dodged.
No way.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Bro, was there 16?
Okay, nice.
Why would that be like the right and not the left?
Like the way some of this is...
Sonic 06.
We caught up to these jerks.
Why do I even wait you're right.
Why do I even need a car?
I'm faster than the car You run all this way.
I'm nowhere near where I started
Why does he even need a bike?
I'm clearly faster than the fucking bike Gains a new power
There's nowhere to hide around here
Did we just leave that guy to die?
I like how we like left the fucking The running kid to die
Like, okay, yeah And we're like, yep, we caught up with him
Anyway There's a huge rocky cliff over there There is?
Where?
Here?
Am I hurrying enough?
Guys, this is the fast I could go This is
I'm going my fastest.
Hurry!
Boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop.
We did it.
Phew.
That was close.
Why is there light from deeper in?
Yeah.
Is there a secret town in there?
Secret?
Ta-da-da!
Secret Ta-da!
What?
That's the spring!
Oh my god, there's trees!
There's a turtle.
How did he get up there?
How did that turtle get up there?
I can't wait to tell the whole world about this one tiny ass
lake.
Yes, there we go.
I wonder just how far the prince got off to.
We should have made him take a walkie-talkie with him.
Man.
No, that wasn't me.
That was...
Hey, old man.
Prince, where are you shouting from?
Hello, did you forget about my telepathy?
Anyway, enough about that.
Guess where I am right now.
Where are you at?
I don't know.
Where?
The spring.
I found your legendary spring.
We did it.
Can it be?
You really made it to the spring?
Yeah.
What?
You telling me the word of a fiend He's not good enough for
you.
Sorry.
So, where is it?
It's like inside a rock.
In your mom's house.
This is Aare.
May I have a moment, sire.
What is it, General Aare?
I'm in the middle of a meal right now, you know.
Whoa.
Wait, he gets second dinner?
You hardly ever contact me to...
Oh!
Don't tell me you've gotten rid of Shiva already!
My apologies, Sire.
You see.
Supreme Commander Zayu just told me something.
He said you had personally ordered him to carry out the
genocide of the Peachy and the destruction of the Tank
Brigade 30 years ago.
He... he what?
Why would he tell people that explosion was deliberate now
of all times?
Anyway, that is a bold-faced lie.
Zayu came up with that entire plan all in his own.
Oh my god, he already threw him under the rock.
I see.
Yes, I am still pursuing Shiva, Sire.
All right, out.
He's getting bamboozled.
He's shifting the blame.
I can't believe it.
It's true.
All of it.
Put me through the general.
Shiva now.
I can't believe it was true this entire time.
Inside this rock formation?
Incredible.
I'm just wondering, has he ever even seen a tree in grass
before?
I can't believe it.
Like, in his lifetime?
I know, right?
Aren't you impressed?
Okay, let's split up and look around.
Look around for what?
we found it wait where are we like this was the whole
mission we found this see can i run on water now oh my god
wait this water is like oh okay there we go i was gonna say
i was like this is not very deep like now i'm gonna
contaminate the water
Don't bathe in the water.
Just remember when you drink that water.
Oh, it's the fucking...
These houses!
It's the Toriyama houses!
What the fuck is a monkey?
Just remember when you drink that water.
Remember it.
Remember who touched it.
I gotta go Go the other way side I go this way
Yeah, the water is like tainted with oh my god the crocs
deal Fando Oh wait, nice.
Okay, I can All right, it's okay.
Some people would drink it if like I don't want to say Even
if it was it was touched by feet someone's here it's here i
mean there's houses here
wait are these uh peaches i told you they're like the nomics
from the from from dragon mall z now i can sell demon prince
bathwater little thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you bro what the is that supposed to be like the
female ones
that who are you get back here they're like evolve versions
like i am the chief of this village this guy looks like he's
from star trek in a thousand years this is what the this is
what they're gonna look like they're gonna their ears are
gonna fall off because they're already bald already yeah so
like the ear in a thousand plus years, their ears are going
to fall off and they're going to be tiny.
I was searching for the spring.
A demon by yourself?
No, I came with my friends.
Thief and Rao.
Rao, if what we heard on the radio is correct, isn't that
the name General Shiva goes by now?
Yeah.
Then you're saying Shiva's at our doorstep.
Wait, he's the war criminal.
They killed their family.
I mean, he still committed it.
Like, that's not going to exempt him.
He killed maybe millions of people or aliens.
It sounds like he has had much on his conscience these many
years.
When you go back, tell him the past is forgiven.
He did the crime, but not the time.
And I have a request.
Oh, that's not what, how you, that's how you, like, forgive
it in War Criminal.
All they have to say is, like, I'm sorry.
You have my gratitude.
Need anything from the outside world?
Bet Rao'd be happy to bring it by later.
Oh, that would help immensely.
I mean, Vegeta got, oh, yeah, because he was hot.
There's many canned goods, articles of clothing, and shoes
as you can get your hands on.
You got it.
He had abs, too.
Hot people can get away with a lot of things.
I'm just...
Like he had murderers.
Okay, wait.
rob them they have stuff i can steal from them poros can't
believe foreigners have made their way wait i wouldn't they
be the foreigners because they're literally aliens like i
don't why did he call me the foreigner hello hello they're
literally the aliens
They're in a peachy race.
Now they own this now.
They aren't aliens.
I thought the peachy race were the aliens.
Like this is my home first.
Let's see this way.
Oh there's a chest here.
Yay.
They're second generation.
Okay, that was, that, that was good.
Rob, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Remember, Doki, whenever you do war crimes, oddities, give
them a puppy face and say, I'm sorry.
Thank you, super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, some peachy survivors and their kids.
I told them the truth about what happened 30 years ago.
from they are they literally came from under earth that's
practically earth
weren't wiped out after all forgive me prince I have no
right to ask this of you but could we just leave this look
some of these peaches were born on this earth now so they're
like second-generation peaches here so he's technically from
earth now I already told the peachy That we'd forget we ever
saw this place.
I should have known you'd say that.
Out of everyone I've met.
I've never known anyone with a soul as pure as you are.
Oh my god, for a demon?
Is there any way to compliment a fiend?
Oh right.
I asked if they wanted anything.
And they said canned food, clothes, and shoes.
What are they...
Of course.
Shoes, clothes and shoes for it.
Once this is all over, I'll load up a truck with anything I
can get and deliver them here.
I can't believe we'll say that to the demon prince.
So, what do we do now?
We have to find the king's water source.
There's something fishy about it.
I just know it.
Yeah, it's not gonna be easy.
You don't even know where it is.
And it's definitely gonna be well protected.
Yeah, what do you need shoes for?
Yeah.
The radio?
Who in the world?
Hey, flip that switch to put it on speaker.
This is General Rory.
I'm just talking to myself, all right?
It sure would put us in a tough spot.
If anyone were to follow the dried-up riverbed all the way
to its southern end...
be pretty bad oh no so terrible but no one's gonna do that
right yeah but no criminals are gonna be listening to this
radio right use a break myself after from the king at the
events of 30 years ago transpired exactly as thief said they
did hell of a shock I nearly burst a blood vessel now I'm
feeling in the mood to talk to myself as well there are
still men of honor serving in the Royal Army I can see more
hope for Sandlands future Wait, what in, like, the other...
What in, like, the main, like, Commander Zayu listen in?
Like, um...
Then what do you post more got?
Oh, my gosh.
Okay, don't think about the plot holes too hard, Doki.
Don't think about it.
He's well aware that Zayu will discover what he's done
before long and that he will be punished for it.
But then why did he tell us?
What does he stand to gain?
Perhaps it's in his blood.
China scorpion father was a great man too after all it just
works oh it's a queen wait he disappeared oh why is she so
mad I don't understand what could she be mad about I don't
understand what did I do what could I possibly done.
Okay, we gotta reload.
I know!
Okay, but look at how tough the exoskeleton is.
My fucking missiles is like a little like love bump, you
know?
It's like a little tap.
Okay, what the fuck is this raptor want to do?
Get out of the fight!
This doesn't concern you!
You!
What are you doing?
There we go.
Nice.
Oh my god.
Get out.
Nice.
I got Creek Queen Exoskeleton.
Uh, we gotta go here.
Real secrets no more.
Uh, alright.
We gotta fast try out Spino.
He's in the splash zone.
Wait, why is there?
Oh yeah, it's just a cat.
Uh, we gotta go this way.
Guys, how many percentage of the game have I done anyway?
I feel like not that much.
All right.
Like, how much percentage of the story am I in?
You got it.
20%?
This is 20%?
Chapter 13 out of 30?
Whoa.
Bro, this already feels like like mid-game.
I feel like I thought I was like um, I thought I was like at
mid-game with the way the story was going.
Apparently I wasn't even mid-game.
I'm chapter 13 of 31.
They roam over Sandland, peddling their wares to all comers.
Okay, I might need more Raptors.
If we find any, let's stop and compare notes with them.
Oh shit, okay, let's kill these guys.
all right okay we need some of their materials what level is
my fucking car anyway okay I mean it's good sign that it's
like a one shot though nice alright I'll get all these mats
gotta absorb this tank and then we gotta to be fair I
noticed that I am missing like three more cars
I need to upgrade my other king to my better my better
dragoon
Oh wait nice oars I love materials I love mats
Okay get over here Maybe the whole demon village could move
there I doubt the king of demons would want no at the reload
I'm gonna play video games all day guys I fucking knew it
was a PlayStation that he gave us I was like that looks so
much like a PlayStation it was like whoa whoa you guys were
like no Doki it's a Saturn and then I read the first chapter
of Sandland and literally they were like oh my god it's a
PlayStation but then of course in the game they had to be
like copyright free so that you could i fucking knew it i
knew my playstations to be any better in your day than it is
now translation error knowing what i do now i fucking knew
it you guys gaslit me into thinking it was a sega saturn was
built on a foundation of sand including what you thought
about demons yeah that too wait can i just jump up most of
all we it's like a slide we we it's like a little slide wait
I could just use my bike it's literally faster I'm so stupid
there you go I can get there faster now
We might be able to reach these inaccessible spots one day.
Supreme Commander Zayu, we have General Aure on the line.
Hello.
It's me.
Give me that.
Can you hear me, Aure?
What kind of lies have you been telling to the king?
The truth!
Wait, has he not listened to the radio?
some confirmation that you haven't completely lost your
mind.
Hello?
Sorry, it seems reception's bad here.
Can't hear what you're saying.
Oh.
No response from the troops guarding the water source or
general R.A.
What?
Dispatch my personal elite guard to the water source.
I thought someone was like, that That dude's in an iron
loathe.
Ha ha ha ha.
According to information from the news office, a criminal
organization attempted to go after the bounty on Shiva's
head yesterday.
We're instead defeated.
He's that strong.
With the help of a young but incredibly powerful red demon.
A young, red demon?
That's...
Beelzebub!
Ashmir!
Sayhu!
Why is Shiva fighting alongside the feet?
He was pink, not red!
I can't believe it!
They miscolored him!
How dare he!
Can you hear me, Dr. Posey?
Prepare the insect men for combat right away!
The insect men?
And deploy our secret weapon as well.
The insect men, that's too dangerous.
They're not yet complete.
I don't care.
As long as they can kill Siba and that demon, they're ready
enough.
I like his pink glasses.
As you wish.
Oh my god, it ain't gonna look like Cybermen.
Okay, how far is this?
Holy shit, that's far.
Wow.
Oh my god.
I wonder what they're going to look like.
I wonder what they're going to look like the Cybermen.
I thought Array said he gave all his soldiers an impromptu
holiday.
Whoa!
They're tough.
Stay on your toes.
It's okay.
I'm just going to...
Honestly, I'm just going to skip all this.
Dude, that's way too many people.
I just shoot the men.
Oh, shit.
I think I reload.
Oh, don't shoot and drive.
Don't shoot and drive.
They always say don't drink and drive, but never don't shoot
and drive.
Oh.
Alright, I can outrun this.
Oh, you're right.
Okay, you're right, guys.
You, like, convinced me by saying loot.
Alright, I'm turning back.
You're right.
You guys always know.
You know I can't resist loot, guys.
You knew.
I might as well.
Phew.
Get over here.
Pupupupupup.
I'm going to run you over.
Okay, we got to get rid of him and him too.
Alright, nice.
That should be enough loot.
No survivors.
The moment I hear Luke, they're all dead.
It's time.
Oh my god, these guys interrupted my plot.
My lore.
How dare they?
That's so fucked up.
We gotta get rid of these little guys, though.
And...
Okay.
They're almost dead.
come on dragons you guys can do better than that you used to
one-shot people this is why you're not better dragons okay
just like one tank that's living all right nice and boom oh
nice we leveled up we did it and then bike time
Wow.
We didn't see that.
All right.
I wonder how fast we can go.
We can only go like 98.
Oh, if we go straight.
If we go straight, it goes up, right?
What if I can upgrade?
Do I have enough now?
No, I just need one more.
What would you do if you ran into a tough enemy?
Let's see.
Well, I'd start by observing them carefully.
they can do and what they're oh great we're at the southern
tip and there's no water anywhere oh my god maybe so wait do
you think like now that i can play like bandai games should
i play jump
the best fighting game out there do these old eyes deceive
me yeah
It's a damn Jump force, you know, jump force The greatest
The greatest Shonen crossover Of our time What do you mean?
We can have Naruto fight Goku
There's the There's the
How do we get up there?
Like this way?
Why is this this way?
all right and then we go this way drift my god it takes so
long the turn
what the fuck how did they get over here looks like there's
something they really don't want us to see yeah what is the
twist there has to be a twist here well obviously there is a
twist because
No.
No, there's like one!
Nice.
And then absorb.
Okay.
Oh no.
I have to walk now.
My legs.
I have to use my legs.
Alright.
Time to use my legs.
Yeah, but there's a deep, dark secret.
What could that be, though?
Over where exactly?
Yeah, where do we go?
I'm here.
Let me drink some water.
Gotta stay hydrated.
Look there.
Yeah, there it is.
What?
What the fuck?
I don't believe it.
They damned up the whole river Wait, so there's water this
entire time Then the river didn't dry up on its own Wait, is
it?
Are we like the only country with no water?
That's so fucked up!
Like, the rest of the world's okay!
It's just this area!
I'm seeing this
Understand humans You'd go this far Bro, that's why there's
no planes So they can't fly over And see it It was literally
just this one area That stupid king is no more than a puppet
Dancing on Zayu's strings So Just this place First We
destroy this damn It's just like attack on Titan all over
again There's a world beyond the sandland but you like okay
like okay like there's like sandland America is just out
there and just being like bro what the fuck is going on over
there the sad land equivalent of America is just outside
with all the water looking at them be like what the fuck is
happening yeah yeah
We know all lands are sand?
They...
They actually created it?
Wait, what's this?
I seriously...
Yeah, Waterland.
That was the Sandland stays in Sandland.
Not a loss for words now, are you?
Just wait right there.
But Sandland, not Sand World.
I promise you that I will make it quick.
this is bad we'll be picked off hurry instead of to the base
i'm heading down oh my god i'm going down yes guess guess
guess guess give me a sec give me like three seconds to get
my car out okay i don't know what's going on behind me i
hope my mpc friends are okay
those pesky rats refuse to die
Dr. Pussy?
Are you really sure about this?
We still haven't been able to achieve complete control over
them.
Once they defeat the enemy, they may turn on nearby
civilians.
Oh, for that matter, us.
Sorry, it's Pussy.
Sorry, it's French.
What's that
round thing?
Can it be?
Get it right, Doki.
It's French.
Oh my god, it hovers?
I'm surprised.
It is like the Frieza thing.
I could say the same to you.
Then again, you're too power hungry to let even death get in
your way.
Why do you always have to go and cause such...
trouble Shiva why can't you leave things in peace peace
make-a-wish freezer is this tyranny what you call peace I
know everything say you I hope you're prepared for the
consequences you should be prepared for the consequences of
crossing me you have no idea who you're dealing with dr.
Posey now
What's he gonna do now?
Oh, it's the InSigman!
Freeza from Team U.
What did it look like?
What's that?
Prince, that pod.
I don't like the look of it.
Yeah, I know.
There's a nasty smell.
Okay, it's not their fault.
There's no showers in there.
Look how tiny the pods are.
It's not their fault.
Ugh.
Oh my god, this looks like a Cyberman.
Oh, never mind.
It does not look like that.
Never mind.
It was just the arms.
Growling.
It's just a bug.
This is our ultimate.
One person?
Oh, demons!
How can the bugs kill demons?
Oh, dang.
I'll admit, that thing does look dangerous.
Old time.
Incent men actually looking like an insect?
That's crazy.
We have to sell at home.
Will you be okay?
Just running over with a fucking car.
A bug is still a bug I think you guys are forgetting an
important fact.
I'm a fiend Hey ugly if you want to run now, I'll let you go
help Oh my god Guys, I don't think he liked that Dad, what
the fuck?
You're not so tough.
No.
Better be careful, Shiva.
There's one weakness, a fucking punch.
We'll attack any and every living creature on site.
Oh, shit.
My bad.
What the fuck put your shirt back on?
He never had a shirt.
God, he looks so much more naked without the cape.
Makes me feel so weird.
It's just weird.
He's just...
Sorry.
Come on, then.
Bring it.
Is it because he has no kniflers?
Maybe that's why.
Appreciate it, old man.
But it's way too dangerous for you.
Got it?
Hide in the tank with feet.
Oh, shit, critical!
Right off the bat!
Bro, how did you get a critical that fast?
Guys, I fucked up.
Guys, I learned how to lock in.
It only took me, like, it only took me, like, a couple of
playthroughs.
Jesus Christ.
Christ.
Okay, we gotta get out of the way.
Oh, ha.
You almost got me, bro.
Oh, shit!
He's, like, stomping on me like a bug!
He's treating me like the bug!
I like how, like, it's just one of them that's taking
fucking forever, but there's, like, 20 pods behind us.
Like...
That's, like, the awkward part.
No, no, no, no, no.
Oh, okay.
I was gonna stay outside.
Miss.
Like, there's literally 20 different pods.
I did it.
Oh.
The other pods are easy.
Oh, there's more.
Oh, that's awkward.
Oh no!
Oh my god!
It's not blood, it's just saliva.
Believe me, you haven't really seen the prince yet.
You demons have been a thorn in my side for decades.
But with this, it won't be long before none of you remain.
Like how the theme was like, don't help him.
Every wonder estimates Prince B.
Elzebub.
Because of how kind-hearted he is.
you seem to have forgotten something he said he is the most
fearsome fiend in the world he was telling the truth it's
gonna be a super scene and unleashes the power of darkness
you'll learn the meaning of fear i don't know it's these i'm
not getting convinced right now oh
is this it
he's gotten up haven't seen him get this man he's actually
go-ahead let's get a bit further back how long do you intend
to just stare off into space he's only bluffing finish him
off this instance oh my god there we should be far enough
away now whoa where the fuck was that I once got too close
and nearly paid dear holy shit now they're just level 10
Bro, I don't even need a dodge anymore They're like two hit
Holy shit Thousands and millions of dollars of dollars of
research Dead by one fucking kid by one punch from a child
oh shit oh no getting their ass beat that's what he's gotten
super sated dead by one angry little guy bro that's like
millions dollars of research right there that's like water
money they
lost all the water money I
can't believe it what power see I told you how how can this
hat can you understand me if you can then we don't need to
do this
If you can't kill Piazza above yourself, just self-destruct
and take him with you.
Don't know, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Would you take away the Coco villain?
His iron lung!
How would he breathe?
Guys, he'll be okay.
Nobody dies in this game.
He'll be okay.
That's like just like 80 feet.
It's not that bad
How did he live that thing went what that should have hit
his fucking body
Oh I surrender
Get a jacket enemy who's already surrendered I'm no threat
Commander Zayu.
He's committed war crimes.
One more kill would mean nothing.
To be fair, he's gonna die of old age, like in one next
week.
General Shiva, reporting for my new assignment.
I'm off of.
General, we'll protect our home, no matter what it takes.
I'm a father now.
Here's my son.
Isn't he cute?
You're back.
Oh, there's Sexy Terrier.
Oh.
That was Sexy Terrier.
For you, I have no mercy.
Do it!
Pull the trigger!
Is she dead?
Did he do it?
Did he actually do it?
Bro.
He didn't do it.
What a fucking little bitch
Did your diaper exceeded maximum limit thinking of a super
chat thing?
Still every bit as gullible as you used to be aren't you?
You should have tilt the shine This is bad would you show
some respect?
Oh, he could jump that high?
Why do we need a fucking car to jump?
And now for the grand finale.
Oh my god, we did it.
We're gonna bring back one to the sand.
All right, this is a good spot.
The rest of the world must have been like, what the fuck is
going on?
Wait, wouldn't we?
like drown we should not be sitting standing here i feel
like the water is gonna fuck us up
what bees above never killed anyone yeah it'll be okay it's
just the flesh ruin many thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you with your tanks as well worth a try i'm not
sure that's gonna cut it either So even the great Shiva
himself can't break down a wall this thick
The swimmers the swimmers Those rats they must have followed
us here What you want to have another go Wait a minute We
just wanted to give you a chance to purchase this here
beauty Bro, you want to swim, don't you?
That's a blast you're damned of bits.
I guarantee it.
How's 30 million Zeni sound?
Bro, we're fucking broke.
I'm a child.
How would we have money?
You seem pretty friendly with the army.
Isn't that just a drop in the bucket to them?
Bro, they spent everything on those insect men and then I
beat the shit out of them.
Unfortunately, I'm about to be canned for betraying my oath
of duty.
I'm in no position to spare so much as 3,000, any, let alone
30 million.
What?
Dang, there goes my payday!
But, Papa, you said you'd part with those shells for free!
Idiot?
Shut your trap!
Fine.
Let's just say you guys owe me one.
Prince that ammunition is precious do not miss Wait I know
what I'm doing I didn't get off I can't get off What if I
miss Okay that's fine I can I have I can have one There's
eight bullets guys If I miss all eight then that's something
oh my gosh i should have seen i wouldn't know i would have
like been like if i missed all eight we should have not
stood why are we like this close to the dam
don't just stand there gawping think for a second anyone in
the riverbed is going to be swept away that's right should
we have done this before i have an urgent message the entire
nation just had no water everybody else is just like what
the fuck is going on in there as soon as possible we could
have said this before we shot the dam
guys we found fruit the moment the dam
yeah you need to reveal the truth behind the senseless
genocide of the peachy in the near future for now rejoice in
the return of the river in peace to this land no food my ass
i know right what the meaning of this general is it true
that the water has returned to the river yeah for everyone
in sandland again oh oh is that so how wonderful and the
attack on the peachy was a heinous conspiracy carried out by
commander zeo who acted with full knowledge that what he was
doing was wrong where the king is gonna get away with it how
about this why don't you share half of your own personal
fortune with both the citizens of this country and the few
remaining peachy huh if rumors got out about you being
complicit in zeo's scheme to cause and profit off the water
shortage that might sully your reputation suggest making a
serious effort to recapture the hearts of the people unless
you want me it's gonna blackmail him
yes of course get rid of the monarchy bravo sire i would
expect nothing less from our esteemed and honorable king of
sandland Because military rule is also is definitely a
better alternative The military will be in your hands
instead of zeus Me commander don't be absurd.
I intend to retire from the army Is he retired with what
money you literally have like not he just told us you don't
have money anymore Just another villain You should be the
next supreme commander You're joking.
I'd never join the army again you're the only choice for
supreme commander go make a real king out of our foolish
monarch and protect the peace okay now shall we go home
we'll have them lend us the tank for a little bit longer
yeah yeah free
tank so say you is no more wait that's not the end who the
fuck are These people!
Dispatch our troops at once.
Remember, secrecy is imperative.
That's chapter 14 out of 30.
Guys, it's not over.
What the fuck is this little shithead?
I already don't like him.
rest in the palms of our hands oh yeah this is like the
country outside of sandland who's like what the is going on
there with no water like fury to unleash fury for the jade
is above attack will be press rb okay rb and rn okay use rbx
to use the explosion that was one powerful blast of water i
wonder if it's reached vino yet all right apparently this is
not the end guys this is only chapter 14 now we have a whole
other country to conquer
it looks like water's returned to spin oh too wait then this
is not sand land anymore it's like just land land land look
how happy everyone is you were the ones who brought their
smiles give the credit to the old man the rest of us were
just along for the ride
of course now then i think it's time we paid our respects to
the people who supported us along the way can i finally use
my chairs off you go then i'll be in the garage
Can I finally use my 50 chairs?
So you won't take me in?
What the fuck is this kid?
Well, this isn't a decision I can make on my own.
Yeah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
What's up?
Polak here wants to live in Spino.
You're a peachy.
Don't tell me you traveled here from the legendary spring
alone.
I did.
seeing all of you made me want to explore the world too that
was reckless of you explore the world that's still like the
same area you just walked like like a couple of miles and
was like world explored i just knew i had to come visit i
swear i'll make myself useful won't you let me stay i mean i
don't really mind but what can you do exactly for starters i
can cook the laundry better than anne wow that's impressive
yeah i was gonna say he's already betty i want that guy and
said be sure but your skill with machines more than makes up
for that i want to see the real dad too oh i'm good with
machines he's the peak probably my forte bro he's even good
we don't need anne we don't need anne i'll just have him do
everything the peachy for you the town will grow now that
the water's back they'll need better add can i rename him
i'll personally ask your tour to let you stay here thank you
better add now you just need a new name now what about here
are you sure yeah it's too big for me by myself plus i want
to see This animal green child.
I thought up a way to soup up the jump bot.
Interested?
Really?
Let's do it!
Wait, what is he gonna do to my jump bot?
See no more.
What did he do?
Oh, I could go higher!
Nice.
Whoa, awesome!
I could do this much in my sleep.
Gaining arrivals turned her into a show-off.
Way to go, Anne!
I need to follow your example.
Thank you, one and all.
I promise to pull my weight.
The jump bot is now more powerful.
You can jump even higher.
Make good use to explore new regions.
Oh, nice.
Where's Better Anne?
Alright.
I'm going to use the bathroom real quick.
I'll bear it back.
You can look at Better Anne.
Ginger, Miracle, Alan, Duck, and Sess.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, it's time to upgrade our vehicle.
Wait, can I just talk to Polak to upgrade my stuff?
Thank you, one and all.
No!
What if I want better end to fix my vehicle?
I like it more.
It's not fair.
Alright, let's see.
We have the materials to upgrade to this.
And then, might as well.
Alright, and then...
I don't have enough mats.
Oh, I still need the fucking raptor steel.
I always need the raptor steel.
Okay, does it make it faster?
Okay, actually, I don't need to upgrade I'm not gonna
upgrade Scam.
I'm not I realize I don't need to upgrade Scam.
Alright, let's See, 162 Uh 28 28.
I can upgrade this actually.
No, I cannot.
I can upgrade this though.
Okay, max.
Uh What about...
Alright, nice.
It maxed out.
Okay, we don't need to upgrade Scam.
I'll never upgrade Scam.
I'll never upgrade you.
Alright, here we go.
Okay, we gotta go to see the mayor!
Wait, that's not the mayor.
We gotta go back up here?
Is the mayor up there?
He's so far.
fast?
Yes, but my upgrades don't upgrade the speed, guys.
It doesn't upgrade the speed.
It just attacks an HP and we don't need to worry about that.
Where do I go?
Where the fuck is the mission?
Oh, it's here.
The demon village.
Oh, I had to go back home.
I had to go back home and be like, I'm back, guys.
I'm back.
I did it.
Welcome home, Prince.
Guys, I got us water.
Yo!
You better not have been gaming while I was away.
Of course not.
We've been waiting patiently for your return this whole
time.
Oh, yeah?
Upgrade Scam, you coward!
Thank you for the acoustic fun.
Thank you.
It's time to get my game on.
If Scam had 100 fans.
I'm one of them.
Scam has zero fans.
It's because I'm dead.
Biggins number...
Scam's number one fan.
Oh, yeah.
Right.
I should go tell everyone back at Aputo Village what
happened to.
Gotcha.
You think you'll drop by again?
Sure.
Once things settle down.
Ha ha.
See you around then.
Goodbye, Grandpa.
I did it, Dad.
Boppity.
He's the only remaining Dragon Ball Z character to live, to
survive.
I gather your journey was fruitful.
Big.
the buddha good you may leave
how about we bump up game time to an hour and a half
he's the only one to lived out he outlived uh he had lived
all the other dragon ball z characters he's acquitted i get
to play 30 minutes more well maybe i I'm being too hasty.
Perhaps I should give these human games to try before I
judge them.
Yay!
I got I got game time.
Wait, he's back?
What the fuck?
Why is he back?
I did my job.
Oh my god, am I gonna get two PlayStation's?
These supplies are for them.
Want to come?
Yeah, I do.
Oh, shucks.
I guess I'll tag along too.
Now for season two.
Oh, that's right.
I've got a present for me.
Got this bot part as a peace offering from those little
punks who wrecked my car.
Figured you'd like it.
Nice.
Thanks.
It's going to be a long drive let's make a pit stop at spino
sounds good oh hey old man what you been oh we're gonna make
a pit stop let me oh my gosh it's such a long drive sorry i
skipped your lore
what's up old man you see something funny no i'm just
surprised at how glad i am to be back in spino why don't you
just move in here for good it's just not that easy well
we've got a long journey ahead of us make sure there's
nothing left you need to do first oh that means like uh this
is like the last time we're gonna be here question mark is
that it is that why you said that damn all right i'm sorry i
need to i do things for money you you'd understand right and
you do things for money too all right where is where is scam
upgrade vehicle the one time i upgrade scam oh my god it's
croxy bro i have to use my
I'll see you later.
I skipped the important lore.
Guys, can you guys give me like a quick, like, a quick wiki
dump of what the lore was?
Ready to head out?
Yeah, I'm ready.
I think I did everything.
I got blue upgrades?
Not yet.
I got upgrades, apparently.
Not yet, guys.
Wait, can I...
Do I have it here?
You already got that.
Extra armor!
Wait, I better have extra armor.
What the fuck?
What better dragons?
You're already good.
You don't need anything, apparently.
Shotgun grenade.
Okay, nice.
Quest in the middle.
No, that should...
That's just Miao Jin Bu.
I mean, I could talk to him.
I don't think I'm gonna be doing anything, but I could talk
to him.
Hey!
Nice to see you again.
Is it just my imagination?
Or has the town gotten more lively?
Oh, yeah.
I found something cool.
Oh, shit.
Raptor Steel.
I need that.
Wait, he actually gives me stuff?
God.
We don't need treasure.
We don't want to fucking...
I haven't found any ruins.
Alright.
I'm ready.
I'm ready to go.
Yeah.
Yep.
All good.
Let's hit the road then.
Yeah.
Have you been back to see the Peachy at all since we busted
the dam?
I've still got enough.
I'll keep them lore before I fast travel.
South alone.
That's done?
Alright, where is it?
Yeah!
Fast travel!
We did it.
I wonder if the Peachy could make me a new game console if I
asked.
You'd be lucky to get off with cleaning the whole village if
King Lucifer found out about that.
Hello, Elder.
Well, what brings you here today?
much but we've brought some provisions for the village i did
it oh that is extremely kind of you of course i'm a con
person at least i could do to attempt to atone for my crimes
if there's anything else you need just ask i'll keep it in
mind but let me give you something in return whoa an
exchange maybe this would be of some use to you watch this a
gun What the fuck is this guy doing with a gun?
Yes, designed for self-defense.
A gun.
Non-lethal.
Bro, what am I gonna do with a non-lethal gun?
Really?
That does sound handy.
What?
Quite the peaceful solution to conflict, wouldn't you say?
The peaceful solution.
It's okay, it's not lethal.
It's just a tazer.
It's a good gun, guys.
As a sheriff, I'm sure you can make good use of it.
Definitely.
Thank you.
Well, we best be on our way.
Can't you stay a little longer?
We've much to catch up on.
Let me tell you about all the people that survive from your
murders.
I suppose we don't have to leave right away.
You want to hang out with all the people you fucking
traumatized for the rest of their lives?
I might as well go to the radio tower.
I realize we haven't done anything with the radio tower over
there.
Let's head to the radio tower.
And then we'll talk.
Hello, monkeys.
Oh, I can't punch when I'm running.
How do we get to the radio tower up top?
Oh my god.
let me in oh okay i can just go in nice we can repair it
yeah we can we have so much materials
okay then we steal the area yay all right let's talk to this
person
you look happy what you up to i
can what is it what the is that oh What's this?
Is it food?
I wouldn't if I were you prince You worry too much.
Yeah, stop worrying Oh, it's like candy Oh, I can fly Whoa,
what is this?
I'm floating.
Can I fly?
Cool, it's so cool Yeah, you got me I thought it was candy.
Eat all of them!
If I eat all of them, I'll fly even higher!
It's called a floaty tablet.
You could have more if you want.
Wonka if he made peas.
I can't see how these will be useful, but sure, why not?
Anyway, you peachy are good with bots, right?
Can you fix a broken game console?
Yeah, even a baby could do that.
really can i bring it next time my console's been broken for
ages no not the console sweet
michael thank you for the super chat thank you thank you fun
fact non-lethal guns are actually called less than lethal
nowadays this thing is technically kill when using the head
and at point blank you know what to do with it thank you for
this super chat thank you thank you holy I mean, that's
true.
Especially, like, you can actually, like, lose an eye from
it, too, and shit like that.
Alright, let's see.
We gotta...
I can fly now!
How do I eat it?
How do I eat my item?
Consumables.
What's it called?
What the fuck is it called?
The floaty tablet?
I can't even actually eat it!
It's just...
aesthetics in my inventory.
Alright.
Nice.
I got standard spring and standard gear.
I can't believe it.
I just, just, it's just there to look pretty.
It's just there to take up my inventory space.
At least there's no, like, weight in this.
So I don't have to worry about being cumbered.
He left the village.
Saying he needed some time alone.
Oh no, He's emo.
Alright, let's go after him.
Alright.
Would you pass on a message to Rao for me?
Even now that this vast river has returned, there are some
mistakes that can't be washed away.
But with the help of your new companions, your future can be
bright and unblemished.
He's just suffered from PTSD at the moment.
Got it.
I'll let him know.
Alright.
I think I'm gonna call it here guys.
Oh my god, I've been playing for four hours Okay, not gonna
lie the longer I play this game.
I feel like the better it gets I'm gonna go save, but I'm
not gonna show you guys the save because I don't know if
it's gonna like freak out again But I've been enjoying the
lore of the store it's freaking out by the way, so that
that's good that like Let's get that I tabbed it out for you
guys but I've been enjoying the game a lot so far I think I
like I've been the story has been like pretty interesting
and like apparently um where we stopped at uh when we
defeated the commander is where the manga ended manga and
anime ended right or is the manga anime still going I don't
know sure not sure and the anime is still going but um so
like after that is when there's like new stuff i haven't
watched the anime before so like i don't i'm not sure yet
because i wanted i wouldn't implied um but the story so far
i really actually uh i actually really enjoyed the story so
far and the fact that there's more to it it felt like it was
the end and then they were like by the way this is only
chapter 14 of 31 i'm like huh 14 out of 30 what you mean 14
out of 31 uh but i uh it's been very enjoyable so far it
sucks that this game isn't more popular i thought this game
would have been like super popular because it's the first
game released post like the passing of tori uh toriama um
and the fact that like i think it's also because okay i
think not gonna lie i think the reason why this game was not
is not as popular Because Stellar Blade released at the same
time So and Stellar Blade had more like I guess like There's
more more things going around with Stellar Blade Than there
was about like in terms of like There were a lot of things
news going around with Stellar Blade So
So um um so it's unfortunate that sandland released at the
same time and um and yeah stellar blade got a lot of free
publicity um but i honestly really i've been really enjoying
i've been really enjoying uh um sandland so far cats thank
you for the super chat thank you thank you the story is
super cool never heard of sandland before but i really
wanted to get into the manga and game show now Thanks for
the stream on it so far.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, it's actually, I've actually been enjoying it a lot
late, like the story.
And I think it's also because it's like an action RPG.
I know I'm not doing a lot of the side quests because I've
never been like a side quest person.
I really, I really just want to know more about the main
story too.
I found the main story to be really interesting.
But I just want to progress the main story just to see
what's going on.
And, like, just want to see what's going to happen next.
Also, the vehicles are really fun to use and stuff.
And your town has no features.
Because there's no side quests.
When can I use my chairs?
Is it because I didn't do the side quests?
So I can't use my chairs?
Is
that...
Anyway, okay, okay, so We are going Oh, yeah, it actually is
Oh, okay Yes, 100% Okay, I haven't unlocked it yet Because I
haven't done any of the Sod quest Sod quest locked No!
Anyway, it is time as I mentioned before um it's two steam
codes two PlayStation codes and two Xbox codes so I'm just
gonna what I'll be doing is I'm literally just gonna I'm
literally all I'm doing is just copy and pasting the code in
the chat but I'll give you guys um I'll give you guys a like
warning before I do so I'll post the first code right I'll
post the first code I'll do a countdown are you a countdown
five four three this is a steam code by the way i'm doing
the countdown again this is the steam code five four three
two one here's the first one good luck good luck good luck
you know i'm going to do an interchange and then the next
one will be like all right good luck anyone is it activated
now has it been activated yeah good luck getting free for
all who got it someone got it who got it who was the lucky
one tell us me smile all right okay all right this one is
playstation i press cancel by accident this one's the
playstation code so people who are on the playstation i hope
you have booted up no it's two each but i'll i'm just going
like down one by one so all right this is the playstation
code whoever has their playstation up all right guys boot
your playstation four or five it's like both i'm pretty sure
i think it's like i'm honestly i think if you have a place i
don't know honestly maybe it's playstation 4 it just says
playstation so boot up your playstations are you Do you guys
have your PlayStation ready, guys, to activate this?
Do you guys have it ready?
Lag is crazy.
Look, the moment you see the code, then you're fine.
Okay.
Five, four, three, two, one.
Boom.
There you go.
All right, get your Xbox ready.
Guys, Xbox is next.
Xbox is next.
Who has...
Okay, the PlayStation people actually have to type this out.
So, like, they have to type this out.
Oh, by the way, the Xbox code is fucking long.
Oh, I see someone got it!
No!
Draven, congratulations!
The Ice Dragon!
They got the Sandland!
Congratulations!
The fastest PlayStation type.
Okay, Xbox is next.
You guys got, okay, the Xbox one is fucking long.
Don't keep running a code fight pit.
We who are about to die salute you, I guess.
AV, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Get your Xbox out, guys.
Power what?
three of you.
I bet you guys can get it.
Oh, you claimed the PlayStation code on the website?
Guys, okay, I didn't know that.
I thought you had to type this out.
I don't know about Xbox.
Can you guys claim it on the website as well?
Alright.
Alright, are you guys ready?
Log into Microsoft Store on your PC.
Oh, shit, the Strats.
The Strats, guys.
That's cheating.
We had to go buy an Xbox box please okay are you guys ready
i'm gonna do a countdown five four three two one boom and
then a surprise twist i'm not gonna go back to the pc yet
the pc the last pc steam code will be the last one i'm
giving out the next one is playstation i'm giving out
another playstation
i told you it's long i was like get ready it's pretty
fucking long
I don't know I just got the code I'm not supposed to know
countdown is useless when there's 30 seconds of lag I press
redeem without confirming did anyone get it did anyone get
it damn that's cheating what do you mean that's cheating I
know Okay, I do it 10 seconds, so when I hit 5, you know
it's ready.
Who's got it?
Okay.
All right, guys, all right, this is a PlayStation code.
I'll give a 10-second countdown.
So when I hit 5, you'll know when this look.
Okay.
10, 9, 8, 7, 6.
Five, four, three, two, one.
This is the PlayStation.
And then we're going to go with Xbox Next.
I like how someone's like typing, you coward.
Oh, my God.
I really like the person.
I'm just like, stop.
Don't you dare copy and paste it.
I got it, Creeper.
Creeper!
Congratulations on getting the PlayStation code!
Alright, last one, guys.
Not last one, sorry.
Second last one, because we still have one more Steam code.
Alright.
Xbox time.
The really long one.
Get ready.
Look at the chat at five seconds.
What I'm going to do with the 10 second countdown.
Alright?
Because the five, the 10 second delay.
Or five second delay.
Alright.
Ten.
Nine.
8, 7, 6, 5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
Alright.
I have an Xbox.
I just don't feel like going to my basement.
He's just here for the ride.
It's rigged.
Alright.
There's the long code.
Good luck, good luck, everybody.
And finally, the Steam players, people on Steam, already
redeemed?
Holy shit!
That guy's fast!
Oh my god!
Whoever got that was fucking fast!
Bone viewers have no chance.
Damn speedrunners!
Chat kept moving up and stopped me from redeeming.
Bro, that's fucking evil.
That's actually evil.
They're like, spam the chat quick so they can't get it.
All right, finally, the Steam code.
The Steam code, everybody.
Oh, Azzi, congrats, Azzi.
Congrats on getting it.
All right, here you go.
The last giveaway code of Sandland for everybody.
10, 9, 8, 7, 6, 5, 4, 3, two one there you go this one's
gonna be like going so fucking fast good luck to the pc
people last code the last one yeah the copy and paste i just
got here how is everyone dragon thank you super chat thank
you thank you uh we're doing great we just played four hours
of sandland and had a great time uh who got it i I hit
cancel, bro.
Rest in peace, bro.
Stop typing.
I can't copy the code.
Bro.
Those poor people.
Stop typing.
I copied your name.
GG's.
I don't know.
Who got it?
Who got the Steam one?
I'm on a tank.
I think I got it.
You got it, Chubis.
Congratulations, Chubis.
Kaz, I thought I speed by copying your name with the code.
It choked.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Congratulations, everybody who got the code.
Who got the six copies of Sandland.
Again, a huge shout out to Bandai for giving me free copies.
give away to the dragoons um they didn't have to do that but
they did and i really appreciate it uh appreciate them and
the support like i said before in the beginning i never
really had a chance to really play bandai games um they're
at one point i really want to play digimon but because like
perms issue like we couldn't and then the fact that like
dark guy was like super supportive uh band america was super
supportive of me like playing bandai games in the future as
well I really really do appreciate it and the fact that they
wanted to send me some like send me like stuff too like send
me like a little package of stuff and uh yeah a huge shout
out hey guys I'm gonna call it here today has been a really
long stream and tomorrow we have two streams tomorrow so I'm
gonna call it here everybody thank you everyone for coming I
hope you guys enjoyed today's stream it was a nice like
chill stream um i know it's like part two of an rpg is like
you know uh i knew it wasn't a lot of people were gonna turn
out for this one but um i still wanted to keep going because
actually i've been enjoying the story so far and i've
actually been enjoying the experience of sandland uh but
yeah thank you everybody as always everyone stay hydrated
posture check get up and move around to get that blood
flowing and if you stayed up for me head to bed because you
deserve it i'll see you guys next time everybody bye guys
Bye!
Wait, oh wait, let me, ninjutsu, thank you for the super
chat, thank you, thank you, thank you, I think Bandai should
give one more code, so those of us that choked can get a
second chat, thank you, thank you, thank you, ninjutsu, you
know you're gonna choke again, ninjutsu, it's just gonna get
worse, anyway guys, bye everybody, bye!